Exzellent, exzellent. Chat ist auch am Start. Also Leute, mir geht es schon ein bisschen besser, aber ich habe immer noch ein bisschen Kopfweh.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich am Start bin.
Und ich habe auch dementsprechend nichts mir großartig
überlegt. Also sprich, was man was machen könnte. Aber ich muss euch, ich kann euch was erzählen.
Neuer PC, exzellent. Was hast du gekauft?
Du hast neue PC-Teile gekriegt. Das war wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach, denke ich mal.
Yes.
So.
Aber was heißt, was heißt, wie jeder streamt. Leute, morgen, morgen, ich mache mal kurz meine VM an.
Während der Parrot rare parrottet.
So, kurz mal die VM anschalten.
Morgen müssen wir was machen. Da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Das machen wir eben streamen.
Nein, wir killen heute keine Microcontroller. Morgen vielleicht. Aber morgen müssen wir was machen.
Wie läuft das Laufvideo? Das will keiner sehen. Das war das letzte Mal einfach nur YouTube-Algorithmus-Fail, dass es zwei Millionen Aufrufe gekriegt hat.
Leona Bomber, neunzehn Monate Dankeschön für den Sub. Oder um nicht zu sagen.
So, was wollte ich euch denn jetzt erzählen? Also erst mal kurz den richtigen Hacker-Modus versetzen, das ganze.
Was sagst du zu den Exchange-Exploits? Das ist genau in der Zeit aufgetreten, wo ich übelst Kopfweh hatte.
Ich habe mich damit nur zum Teil beschäftigt. Ich habe gelesen. Wir können uns das jetzt ja mal zusammen angucken.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Plassen-Schimmer davon.
Exchange-Exploits. Ich habe nur gesehen, dass alle voll am Panikschieben sind.
Was sagt denn Halse dazu?
Das Hafnium heißt das. Das habe ich gelesen.
Und dann muss ich mal kurz refreshen. Irgendwie wird mein Viewer-Account hier nicht angezeigt. Warum nicht?
Ah, jetzt. Exzellent, exzellent.
Gab es sogar BSE-Livestream. Ah ja, genau.
Ich habe das mal ganz kurz gelesen. Anscheinend war Microsoft nicht sonderlich schnell, um das Ganze zu fixen.
Microsoft hat aber auch gerade lustigerweise Probleme bei Windows.
Die letzten Windows-Updates. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gelesen habt.
Die letzten Windows-Updates, also nicht die hier, nicht das mit dem Exchange, haben dafür gesorgt, dass es einen Blue-Screen gibt, beim Trocken.
Beim Trocken gibt es jetzt Blue-Screen.
Windows-Logik, Alter.
Timo, Valentino1, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub. Exzellent, Subscription, Huge-Big-Brain-Sub.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe das hier nur ein bisschen am Rande gelesen. Microsoft war wohl angeblich relativ langsam.
Was mich bei der ganzen Sache wieder extrem schockt ist, wie viele Leute Windows-Server verwenden.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich Windows-Server höre, denke ich mir Pains-Champ und mache innerlich...
Nicht so, dass Linux nicht auch genug Probleme hätte, ja.
Aber servertechnisch ist Windows einfach absolut der Krampf. Ich weiß, es gibt viele Leute, die sehen das anders.
Aber aus meiner Sicht, ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich Windows-Administrieren muss.
Es kommt ja manchmal alle Schaltjahre mal auf der Arbeit vor, dass ich mich auf ein Windows-Ding-Remote einloggen muss.
Da kriege ich immer Anfälle, weil man nix findet.
Gut, liegt daran, ich kenne mich eher mit Linux aus, aber man findet...
Ey, ohne scheiß Windows-Settings zu finden, es ist so cancer, Alter.
Das...
Da sagt mal einer...
Da sagt mal einer, das wäre auch nur Linux kompliziert.
Unter Linux ist das das Problem, dass die sich alle nicht an einheitliche Sachen halten können, ja.
Manchmal ist es Minus-Version, Minus-Minus-Version, Minus-Groß-Version.
Minus-Version, Minus-Groß-V, Minus-Klein-V, Minus-H, Minus-Minus...
Ach, was auch immer, Minus-Version, Groß, habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Oh, oh, Leute, Leute, jetzt wo ich es gerade sehe.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, die kommen jetzt nicht an, weil ich mir bei Software-Kong vor allem eine Workstation-Lizenz gekauft habe.
I-Lo, 12 Monate, huge Abo-Falle.
Hyper-Sub-S... Hyper-Sub-Scr... Hyper-Sub-Scr...
FBI ist raus.
Steht vor der Tür.
Hm, immer noch krank, es ist aber besser, es ist besser.
Das liegt eindeutig, also ich hab es jetzt raus gekriegt, woran das liegt, dass ich so viel Kopfweh habe.
eindeutig irgendwie
Hals-Rücken-Mäßig, weil
wenn ich ein bisschen
bisschen
durch Blutungsübung und so mache
Hals-Mäßig geht's instant besser
sowas was ich so mit dem Kopf gegen die Hand drücken
oder irgendwie so Schulter-Action
oder was auch immer
das bringt alles was
ja und deswegen
es ist schon besser, aber
so wirklich, so wirklich geil
ist es immer noch nicht. Ich weiß nicht was ich gemacht habe
ich vermute mal
ich vermute mal das lag daran
wo ich mein
wo ich hier mein AZ
was mein AZ, meinen Serverraum umgebaut
hab
und da musste ich ja
da bin ich ja teilweise hier unten
in der Ecke, guck mal, hier unten
ich bin hier reinge, also ich hab das Rack gedreht
bin hier unten in die Ecke reingegrochen
um die Ecke geguckt und hab da versucht Sachen
anzuschließen
das war
sicher während du an der frischen Luft warst
jetzt wo du es sagst
das kommt zeitlich ungefähr hin
Leute, ein Abo noch für den Scamtrain
das Scamtrain muss uns überfahren
auf geht's
es gibt sein zugewinnt Level 1 Emote
gibt es eigentlich irgendjemand
der diese Emotes verwendet
ich glaube ich hab noch nicht immer im Leben einen Hype-Mode verwendet
das ist ein Hacki
Dankeschön für den Sub
richtig IQ++ für den Chat
wieder
Habt ihr das mit OVH mitbekommen wo das RZ gebrannt hat?
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt wo das Rechenzentrum gebrannt hat hier?
Schneeflocke
3 Monate, Dankeschön
Schneeflockchen
teilt
wegen Schneestells
Dankeschön
Ich hab mal meinen Discord in die Beschreibung gepostet
ja ich weiß nicht ob ihr das mitbekommen habt
jetzt bin ich ja nur froh
dass der Preischamp
nicht bei OVH
oh ich glaube der Preischamp hängt
alternate mindfactory hängt
der Preischamp ist gecrasht
wow
Leute
ernsthaft?
unter
es ist
unter OVP
gefallen
ja gut es ist der 5800
das ist das Ding was keiner haben will
der andere ist immer noch doppelt so hoch
ja ok alles klar
Preischamp ist kaputt
das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben
muss ich nachher den Crawler neu starten
Grauler
ja
so und
bin ich ja froh dass der Preischamp da nicht gehorstet ist
und da hat es
gebrannt im RZ angeblich keine Server
wirklich betroffen
ich weiß nicht
ob das stimmt
habe ich irgendwo gelesen
was ist denn das
IT Projekt Leiter
in
IT Aschi minus Takt
Basis
vielleicht hätte man das ein bisschen
auseinanderschreiben sollen
und dann am Ende ein
Sternchen und in für alles mit
Slash dazwischen
warum
warum vor allem
in wenn man danach doch
WMD dahinter schreibt
gut wir wissen ja alle
das ist weiß männlich deutsch
oder bei den Amis
wisst ihr was WMD bei den Amis ist
wer kennt die Black Ops 1
Map noch
die verstehen nur WMD
was anderes
die verstehen Weapons of Mass Destruction
darunter
ich will mir by the way keine Stellen anzeigen
ok Moment
das muss ich mir kurz angucken das klingt echt
abgedreht Moment Moment Moment
ein Team weltweit das
aussucht zum nächsten
die suchen
3 verschiedene Leute oder
oder suchen die 3 in einem
ne ne die suchen 3
Leute
die suchen 3 Leute in einer
in einer Stellenanzeige
ja ok was auch immer gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an
so wie gesagt AZ hat gebrannt
scheint nicht allzu viel
basiert zu sein an Server Technik
was ich gelesen habe aber das Netzwerk
war halt weg
Strasburg hat es gebrannt
ja
shit happens
kommt vor
mein Ausbilder
damals in meiner Ausbildung
da hat einer zu mir gesagt
wahrscheinlich ist der
bei OVH mittlerweile
der hat zu mir gesagt Max im rechten
Zentrum braucht man keine
Anti
ich weiß nicht ob er gesagt hat Feuerlöscher
Stinger oder
er wollte mir zumindest sagen Max im rechten Zentrum
da braucht man keine
Brandschutzmaßnahmen weil da brennts nie
hat man jetzt
hat man jetzt ja gesehen dass das nicht vorkommt ja
und die Begründung damals bei ihm war
die ganzen Server
die ganzen Server die brennen ja gar nicht richtig
ja aber die Sache drum rum anscheinend
außerdem außerdem
es ist alles nur eine Frage der
Hitze es brennt
mehr als man denkt es muss einfach nur
heiß genug sein ja
ja und wie gesagt zu dem Exchange Hack
ich ähm
ich würde ja was zu sagen
nein Pog aus der Hype Train war
erfolgreich exzellent
oh je
Band Emotes verwendet Toss
alter
ähm ich würde
gern was zu sagen aber ich hab mich null damit beschäftigt
ich hab bloß was denn der
Doktor alter alter mein
Doktor das ist geil
also geil im negativen Sinn ja
ähm ich bin da hin
also ich geh zu dem
Arzt eh nur wenn es mir schlecht geht
weil ich weiß bei dem kriegst du easy ne Krankmeldung
kannst du dann ein paar Tage hinlegen
gut behandelt wirst du dann nicht
äh Scotch Joe 4 Monate
Dankeschön für den Zap exzellent IQ plus plus
für den Chat ich bin hingegangen
und äh
kommen sie rein
hab ich hingesetzt und hab gesagt
ich hab übelst Kopfweh
seit seit 4-5
Tagen schon dann und dann angefangen
und ähm
dann hat er mich gefragt ja was meinen sie bis wann ist wieder gut
was ne Frage alter
was ne Frage
was meinen sie bis wann
ist wieder gut
was weiß ich
ich mein gut was der gedacht hat
ist klar der hat gedacht
der Max der kommt zu mir weil er ne
Krankmeldung braucht
und äh wie lang soll ich den
krank schreiben aber ich bin eigentlich auch unter anderem
dahin weil ich wissen wollte was der dazu sagt
was meinen sie wie lang es dauert
bis wann ist wieder gut
bis wann ist wieder gut hat er gefragt
was meinen sie bis wann wieder gut ist
keine Ahnung
da hab ich ihm noch ein bisschen weiter
weiter erzählt so nach dem Motto ja
also ihm liegen ist besser aber ansonsten ich glaube
es liegt irgendwie so am Hals und ich hab da
Zeug rumgebaut hab mich ein bisschen verrenkt irgendwie
und äh
aber ich hab gesagt 4-5 Tage Kopfweh
ist ganz schön lang für so ein bisschen
verzogen im Rücken ja nicht dass er irgendwie
noch was anderes ist
aber ja sie können ja wieder
kommen
sie können
wieder vorbeikommen wir machen mal bis Freitag
und wenn es nächste Woche dann kommen sie einfach
nochmal vorbei also super
das hat sich jetzt aber echt wahnsinnig gelohnt
dass ich dahin gegangen bin gut doch hat sich gelohnt
für die Krankmeldung also
ich machs ja mittlerweile so ich
ich zeige euch ich erklär euch jetzt mal mein
äh
nicht Businessplan wie nennt man das denn
Healthplan keine Ahnung
so
ich hab weiß nicht wie nennt man das denn
so zumindest
ich mach das immer so ich geht
ich geh zu meinem Hausarzt
Genesungs ne ne
ich weiß nicht wie ich das mit
so generell Ärzte Sache mach und zwar
bedenke dass dein Chef zuschauen kann
ich mir gehts wirklich
schlecht was meint ihr warum ich die letzten Tage
nicht gestreamt hab und keine Videos aufgehoben
hab
Hauptsache ich bin krank geschrieben das ist das
wichtigste was mein Arbeitgeber interessiert
ich hab
das mich da an alles gehalten
ist ja nichts Schlimmes jetzt ne
so und
was wollte ich jetzt sagen
oh Aliexpress da sag ich gleich was
zu das ist eine äußerst
gute Frage hast du mal einen Link zum Artikel was du kaufen
willst
ich lese gleich den Chat ich sag jetzt mal schnell was
zu was wie ich das
Arzttechnisch mache und zwar
was
was ein schlechtes
was ein schlechtes Artikel Bild
ist das das erste Stockfoto
mit Feuer was sie gefunden haben oder was
das ist fein
das ist nicht fein
ok Skillkiller ich
mach das gleich mal auf
ah die sind gut die hab ich auch
die hab ich auch
Moment aber das da oben ist was
anderes
also
was wollte ich jetzt sagen
genau also wie ich das
Arzttechnisch mache
also ich hab meinen Hausarzt das ist der
der taugt überhaupt gar nichts
meiner Ansicht nach also
der kümmert sich meine Mutter ist da früher auch
hingegangen aber der ist ganz vergessen
der untersucht die Leute nicht
der ist gut fürs krankmeldung schreiben also
wenn man wirklich
das gefühl hat es geht einem schlecht
sei es jetzt dass man irgendwie
Erkältung hat sonst was wo du genau weißt
ey das wird nichts schlimmes sein
aber du kannst jetzt ne Woche nicht arbeiten
gehen ein paar tage nicht arbeiten gehen dann gehst du zu dem hin
geh ich zu meinem Hausarzt und jedes mal
wenn ich reinkomme im Endeffekt dauert es 20 Sekunden
da fragt mich und was meinen sie wann ist wieder gut
diesmal hab ich ja nichts gesagt
diesmal hab ich nichts gesagt
ich hab versucht bisschen was aus ihm rauszulocken aber kanns vergessen
der behandelt die Leute irgendwie auch nicht
der hat da keinen bock drauf keine Ahnung aber
mein Hausarzt ist top
bei Sachen wo man weiß es ist nichts schlimmes und man braucht eh ne krankmeldung
und man möchte möglichst schnell
zum Doktor hin und wieder zurück
manchmal muss man gerade in der Corona Zeit
ich hab euch ja erzählt dass ich
Lebensmittelvergiftung hatte vom Lieferdienst
meine erste meldepflichtige
Krankheit die ich je im Leben hatte
da war ich auch bei dem
das hat den nicht interessiert
und ich hab also ich wollte
ich wollte zudem ich hab da angerufen
hab gesagt ey mir gehts schlecht
ich hab jetzt bauchweh und so
seit ein paar tagen es ist
richtig kacke und da haben die noch
gemeint ich kann mir sogar
die können mir jetzt in Corona Zeiten sogar
ne krankmeldung quasi
in Anführung wie Remote ausstellen ich muss die dann nur noch abholen
ok
wunderbar zumindest
ich musste
ich musste zu der an der Anmeldung
sagen
als ich Lebensmittelvergiftung hatte
musste ich sagen soll ich mal
eine Probe mitbringen
dass ihr die ins Labor schicken könnt
dann meint die
das kann ich jetzt nicht genau entscheiden
ich frag mal den Chef
und dann ist die zum Chef
wenn der Chef hat gemeint ja er soll mal mitbringen
das musste ich sagen alter
wenn ich bei einem Arzt anrufe und sag ich bin 4 tage am Dauer
kacke
auf die Idee hätte er auch selbst kommen können
pack mal ne Probe ein
das ist ja damals dann eingepackt hingeschickt ins Labor
und was habe ich gekriegt
nicht etwa, nicht etwa nen Anruf
vom Arzt oder so
nicht etwa nen Anruf vom Arzt
wir haben was gefunden
sondern
nen Brief vom Gesundheitsamt
dass ich das ausfüllen sollte
ob ich in der Gastronomie arbeite
oder nicht
ja
also
wie Zulul ist weg
ich hatte immer Zulul
ist Zulul wirklich weg
Zulul emote
haben die das entfernt? ne
alter oh man
mir geht dieses entfernen von Sachen
immer so extrem auf den Sack
mittlerweile es ist echt der Wahnsinn
du darfst
an absolut nichts mehr Spaß haben
nix mehr sagen und sonst was
ich hab übrigens
Zulul noch geedet auf
FFZ
aber lustigerweise
geht das Zulul nicht
also ich hab aber noch
ah ne es ist rejected
es ist rejected auf
warum
warum ist das verboten das emote
ok also lass mal lesen
warum ist das
entfernt worden
was sonst alter es ist heute
alles sexistisch
rassistisch
was haben wir denn noch alles noch
ich sag nicht dass es nix gibt
in dieser Richtung ja es gibt genug Sachen
wo die Menschheit
daran arbeiten muss
aber man muss nicht überall irgendwie
das zerreden und überall
irgendwas drin sehen ok zeig mal her
was
ne das ist ja auch ein blackface
versteh mich
ich blick da nicht mehr
durch mittlerweile
es ist mir echt zu hoch
bald darfst du dich
nur noch mit
rauchzeichen irgendwie verständigen
dass keiner offended ist oder so
wahnsinn ey
ich mach einfach nen wupp emote
ich mach
wupp zulul
meine güte ey
ok ok leute
ok wo bin ich jetzt
wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben
bei der ganzen sache
also genau
nachdem ich mich jetzt über meinen arzt ausgelassen hab
und also was ich jetzt noch sagen wollte
was ich jetzt im endeffekt mache also
unabstrich behandeln lassen kannst du dich bei meinem hausarzt nicht
das ist voll fürn arsch
was ich jetzt immer mache ist wenn ich was hab
wo ich wirklich will das schnell
mal einer guckt
und womöglich auch was macht
der ahnung hatten sich für die leute noch interessiert
dann bezahle ich das selbst
ich hab jetzt schon
ich war jetzt schon ein paar mal
bei ein paar ärzt und hatte
den kram selbst bezahlt das war nie
ultra teuer also ich bin da nie
irgendwie mit 5000 euro rausgegangen
oder so
sondern eher so im bereich
70 bis 300
je nachdem was die gemacht haben
sag mal so 50 bis 300
300 war das teuerste
und klar
das
ist
wie sag ich das am besten
es wird immer gesagt wir müssen aufpassen dass wir kein
2 klassen gesundheitssystem bekommen aber das haben wir schon
ihr glaubt nicht was das für ein unterschied ist
wenn ihr zu einem arzt geht
ich war beispielsweise in frankfurt
ich hatte mal morgens das ohr verstopft
hab ich im zug gemerkt
hab ich gesagt alter ich hör rechts nicht mal richtig
ja
das ist kacke
so und
hab ich gesagt ok entweder fährst du jetzt heim
gehst du dazu irgendeinem hno arzt
der das ordentlich machen kann
na privat versichern
kann man sich überlegen ob er das macht aber das ist
ja zumindest selbst bezahlen
geht ja auch
und
genau
da hab ich dann gesagt zurückfahren du kannst
vergessen
ne mit luft bringt ja also
du musst das ja raus machen
ist ja auch egal das ist ja eklige angelegen
da muss ich jetzt nicht so lange drüber aus
hab ich dann einfach mal geguckt ok was haben wir
in der nähe für Ärzte hab ich was gefunden in frankfurt
hab ich angerufen
und was war die frage so nach dem motto
ja man passts ihnen denn
ja
13 uhr hab ich mittagspause kann ich so irgendwie
in dem dreh kommen ja kommen sie doch 12.30
vorbei
gar kein problem easy as fuck
echt
so bin ich dahin
und die sind nicht blöd die sind nicht blöd
ja die machen das mittlerweile so
die haben zwei getrennte
wartezimmer ein wartezimmer
für relativ kleines für private
leute oder selbst bezahlen leute
und normales wartezimmer für den
rest weil die wollen natürlich
nicht dass jemand der da einen termin
hat da irgendwie eineinhalb stunden wartet
ein halbes jahr auf den termin schon vorher
gewartet hat die wollen natürlich nicht dass die
sehen dass irgendein dude da reinkommt
sich zwei minuten ins wartezimmer setzt
und zum chef kann ist
ist ja verständlich ja wird mich wahrscheinlich
auch abfacken aber die sache ist
halt die wir können gar nicht mehr sagen wir
müssen aufpassen dass es kein zwei
klasse gesundheitssystem gibt
das ist das ist schon da und wenn man mal ehrlich
ist hand aufs hart das war im prinzip
schon schon wahrscheinlich
nicht so langs die menschheit gibt so
dass die
leute die sich leisten konnten
bessere medizinische versorgung haben
das ist das
ist der der grad dazwischen ist
natürlich geschrumpft ja
also mittlerweile kriegst du ja
gesetzlich versichert kriegst du die notwendigen
behandlungen zum größten teil kriegst du ja
das ist ja alles ist ja alles gut
aber wenn du halt keinen bock hast ein halbes jahr zu warten
und wenn du willst da schnell sich mal einer drum kümmert der sich vor
allem zeit auch nimmt für
die leute dann
ist das das beste was man machen kann
ich wollte
mal beispielsweise zum hautarzt
weil ich
jetzt hört sich jetzt an als bin ich laufend krank
das sind sachen der über ein paar jahre ja
ich hatte irgendwie so irgendwie entzündetes
irgendwie ausschlag
oder sowas weiß ich nicht so
auf dem kopf wollte ich mal dass
sich einer anguckt
letztendlich habe ich mich einfach nur zuviel
gekratzt würde ich mal sagen
an einer stelle und es hat sich ein bisschen entzündet
so ich habe es dann ein paar
tage eingecremt war gut zumindest
habe ich damals gesagt hier meinen kopf habe
ich irgendwie so einen komischen knubbel drauf
müsste ich mal einen angucken habe ich bei meinem
normalen hautarzt angerufen und wisst ihr was
der gesagt hat er hat gesagt in einem
halben jahr in einem
halben jahr haben wir wieder termine
da habe ich mir so gedacht okay in
einem halben jahr in einem halben
jahr gibt es zwei varianten entweder
der kopf ist mir abgefault ab der stelle
oder es ist von alleine weggegangen
das ist genau das was in einem halben jahr passiert ist wenn ich
ein halbes jahr warte darauf ja
so also mal geguckt
hautarzt frankfurt angerufen
auch wieder die frage habt ja wann
passts ihnen denn ja wie siehts denn morgen
morgen nachmittag aus nach der arbeit
wunderbar passt
und dass das ohne scheiß leute das
das krasseste erlebnis
was ich hatte bisher wo ich
halt
privat bezahlt
habe beim arzt war
nicht für mich selbst sondern
für meine mutter die hatte
probleme an der hüfte was man
hat mit irgendwie
ist ganz schön alt jetzt genau
top 70
ist auch egal
die hatte probleme an der
hüfte und die hat rumgemacht hier
wochen wochen lang hat die
hat die damit rumgemacht ja die war
bei meinem hausarzt da wo ich auch war wo jetzt nicht mehr hingeht
und der hat
irgendwelche schmerzenmeldungen gekriegt wo sein
herzprobleme von gekriegt hat sogar so schlimm dass ich den
notarzt rufen muss könnt ihr euch doch an mein tweet erinnern
...
wo ist mein tweet
oah was war das denn jetzt
...
ja genau ich hab doch hier guck mal diesen tweet da vor vor einem jahr nachts 0-10-0
auf meinem krankenhaus sitzen viel wegen meiner wunde nicht wegen mir so die mussten ins krankenhaus
weil du musst sagen ich bezahle selbst oder ich bin privatversichert ja das ist das gleiche
für die so und das habe ich damals gepostet und das war die hatte hüftprobleme schon die ganze
zeit und die hat von meinem hausarzt der halt das absolut falsch diagnostiziert hat kommt ja
auch noch dazu nicht dass er dich nicht behandelt wenn er dich behandelt dann macht das auch noch
verkehrt und der hat ihr schmerzmittel gegeben gegen gegen eine vermeintliche entzündung an
der hüfte arthrose an der hüfte was gar keine arthrose an der hüfte war und das hat die
kreislauf mäßig so mitgenommen dass die die hatten einen pulz von 200 abends gehabt und
habe ich den unats gerufen das war echt absoluter monka es moment ja man man denkt man denkt ja
eigentlich an nichts böses aber da habe ich da habe ich schon ein bisschen schiss gekriegt
muss ich ehrlich sagen also 200 pulse ist nicht normal also dass das da kannst du auch dran sterben
das macht herzmäßig jetzt nicht so lange mit freundlich wenn man 70 ist so und war es im
krankenhaus und als ja noch untersuchen lassen und natürlich im krankenhaus der typ für die
hüfte der hatte keinen bock was zu machen weil man nicht operieren konnte also das hatte dann
überhaupt nicht interessiert großartig hätte man operieren kann so zumindest lange rede kurzer
sind m scherow vom youtube tritt sprahm dankeschön für den sub laut faustregel ist mit 70 210 als
pulse gerade was soll denn 70 210 für pulsen du meinst zwischen 70 und 210 also 210 ist
definitiv nicht nicht ok wenn man 70 ist und im bett liegt vielleicht wenn man vor einem
heifisch wegschwimmt ja jetzt nix ich weiß ob ich richtig ausgesprochen habe jetzt nix
ist ätzend so zumindest um die ganze sache abzuschließen ich habe dann ich habe dann
orthopäde rausgesucht in frankfurt bin ich ich habe dem gleich gesagt ich bezahle das ich bezahle
das termin gemacht zwei tage später termin hingefahren nach frankfurt sich das angeguckt
jetzt passt mal auf die hat glaub zwei monate oder so damit genau im december sind wir dann da
hingefahren jetzt zwei monate mit holen wir sind da hingefahren zwei tage später ein termin
direkt am hauptbahnhof gelegen ausgestiegen in die praxis gegangen der hat sich eine halbe stunde
um die gekümmert ich weiß nicht wann ihr das letzte mal beim arzt wart und der sich hat eine
halbe stunde zeit für euch gehabt das kommt eigentlich nicht vor wenn du länger als zweieinhalb
minuten drin bis kriegt der typ schon panik dass du zu viel geld kostest normalerweise
so eine halbe stunde hat er sich meine mutter angeguckt hat ultra schall gemacht alles und
heute ich habe da gesessen ich habe da gesessen hat mir ganz fack das wird teuer der hat echt
alle register gezogen ja von ultra schall bis zeug und ich habe da gesessen und hat mir nur
gedacht ob das so eine gute idee war weil meine mutter hat die ganze zeit auch erzählt das ist
doch nicht notwendig das geht auch von alleine wieder werden nein nein nein wir gehen da jetzt
hin kann nicht sein dass es zwei monate und nix ja und ich ich saß da halter neben ab keck
weighted so und zumindest zumindest hat sich das echt gelohnt der hat ultra geschalt hat gesehen
er heißt entzündung ist ist entzündung aber keine atrose was der hausarzt einfach gesagt hat
dementsprechend hat der hausarzt sich auch voll das vollkommen falsche mittel gegeben also sprich
die hätte auch nicht ins krankenhaus gemusst wären wir gleich zu dem orthopäde gefahren
wenn ich zum hausarzt weil er hätte nicht das mittel gekriegt was dann die kreislauf
probleme verursacht hat hat hat das ultra geschalt hat festgestellt aha ok entzündung hat ihr eine
spritze gegeben also quasi da genau ans gelenk an die an die stelle hat gemeint kommen sie in
zwei wochen noch mal wieder und schonen sie das ein bisschen ohne scheiß ihr werdet nicht glauben
in zwei wochen war fast wieder alles gut so und jetzt ratet mal was das gekostet hat die war
30 minuten beim arzt drinnen danach noch mal eine viertel stunde beim zweiten besuch es wurde
ultra schall gemacht abgetastet angeguckt beraten und und gemacht und behandelt so insgesamt 45
minuten zweimal das meine was das gekostet hat ich war echt überrascht ohne scheiß ich war
wirklich überrascht ich habe gedacht also ich ich ich aus dem aus dem bauchgefühl bauchgefühl
hätte ich so hätte ich gesagt 4500 euro ok also chat war tatsächlich relativ nah dran es hat 105
gekostet 105 das ist ja nix für so was und die erfahrung habe ich schon öfters gemacht dass das
gar nicht so teuer ist wie man wie man manchmal denkt und seitdem gehe ich auch öfters mal quasi
nicht privatversichert aber mit selbst bezahlen mit zum arzt wenn schnell gehen soll ich will
dass sich einer zeit nimmt sich das anguckt anguckt 105 das wichtigste ist eine sache habe
ich gelernt was man fragen muss ist folgendes man muss fragen mit welchem satz die abrechnen
weil die meisten haben keine keine preislisten irgendwie auf der auf der homepage ihr müsst
die fragen mit welchem satz die abrechnen weil es gibt eine gebührenordnung und das was da drin
steht malen ein gewisser satz rechnen die ab also das geht von eins los normales 2,3 und wenn es
über 2,3 kostet müssen die euch das sagen aber ihr müsst ihr müsst die fragen ihr müsst die
fragen mit welchem satz die abrechnen und ganz wichtig im vorfeld die sollen euch sagen was die
was die machen wollen und was das ungefähr kostet sind das normale ärzte oder machen die dann nur
sowas das war orthopäde der macht halt gelenkrahmen ja und das gibt zwei es gibt es gibt welche die
haben kassen zulassung die machen gesetzlich versicherte und privatversicherte also privatversicherte
und wenn du selbst bezahlt ist es gleiche für den damit das ist kein unterschied also sie machen
privat und und gesetzlich und manche machen nur privat steht dann aber auch dran wenn die keine
gesetzlichen nehmen das muss das muss du fragen du musst die fragen vorher was es kostet ansonsten
kannst du mit 2,3 rechnen weil das der normale satz ist wenn du wenn du wie so ein arzt abrechnen
privat aber ich würde die vorher fragen weil ich habe so die erfahrung wenn man die fragt dann ist
die rechnung danach auch geringer weil die dann weil die dann aufpassen dass ich bezahlt selbst
ich mit welchem satz rechnen sie ab und bevor du bevor du dann auch wenn wenn er dich beraten hat
beratungsgespräch kann er eh schon mal abrechnen 50 euro oder sowas was der vor hat zu machen der
kann dir auch ungefähr sagen was das kostet also es ist jetzt nicht so dass du dass der sagt 500
euro es kostet dann 8000 euro also das ist nicht verkehrt und sobald ihr die fragt wissen die auch
ok du hast ein bisschen damit informiert die könne ich nicht total verarschen also wo mich
einer mal richtig gescampt hat es war diese hno arst in frankfurt der wollte dann irgendwie
am ende 60 euro für zwei minuten behandlung der was der alles abgerechnet hat alter beratungsgespräch
mikroskopische untersuchung bla bla bla bla der hätte höchstens 30 euro abrechnen können für
die eigentliche geschichte kristin hensch sagt nur zum radiologe willst nicht unbedingt ohne
versicherung doch das geht du musst einfach mal preise vergleichen ich habe letztes geguckt falls
so ein mrt machen willst kopf und hals also kopf und und und wirbelsäule kostet das um die 500 euro
oder ich glaube nur kopf 300 oder so ne 300 wirbelsäule 200 kopf irgendwie so das geht das
geht dann schon ein bisschen ins geld aber das passt eigentlich natürlich rechnen die da noch
ein bisschen mehr ab du bezahlst dann 500 für das mrt kopf und wirbelsäule und du wirst dann
wahrscheinlich noch mal 50 oder so bezahlen für gespräch mit dem doktor oder so aber das ist das
ist in ordnung wenn man in betracht zieht dass man eventuell soll sonst erst in drei wochen
oder so dran kommt wenn man schnell haben will wenn ich wenn ich da nicht ja aber ich würde
ich würde wahrscheinlich bezahlen wenn schnell gehen muss naja gut egal lange genug jetzt gelabert
um diese geschichte also ich kann es jedem nur empfehlen der die kohle übrig hat man gibt so
viel man kannst du die jepp ne jepp nicht aber aber buber kann ich hinzufügen ja man gibt für so
viel sachen geld aus und wenn man irgendwelche beschwerden hat mit denen man sich vielleicht
schon monatelang rumschlägt und man kauft sich für 2500 euro im fernsee oder man geht mal zum
doktor für 200 euro das ist keine schlechte investition sage ich euch mit 36 so lange
genug gelabert und jetzt gucke ich mal hier kurz bei aliexpress da wollte ich auch noch was dazu
sagen und dann lese ich den chat durch also aliexpress ich weiß nicht ob der jene überhaupt noch da
ist der das wissen wollte also aliexpress wenn du hast bei aliexpress bestellt das wichtigste was
zum geier ist das ok diese versand art kenne ich nicht was ganz gut ist ist wenn du tracking
bekommst weil ganz ohne tracking ist müll ich würde wahrscheinlich den hier nehmen als versand
erstens weil er schneller geht weil du tracking hast und weil du dort eine recht hohe chancen
hast dass sie das über die niederlande oder so verschicken und es nicht beim zoll landet
ja
bei the way was witzig ist dass der versand aus china das mit unter 21 keinen zoll ist seit diesem
jahr geschichte das ist nicht mehr so es ist abgeschafft aber das macht nix weil die chinesen
die sind ja doof haben wir letztens erkannt ja die chinesen bauen auch spannungswandler
wo 3,3 volt drauf steht aber 12 volt rauskommt und also die sind nicht die sind nicht doof die
chinesen was die machen bei aliexpress ist die chinesen wenn die nach eu verschicken
haben die drei varianten entweder sie schicken es direkt aus china zu euch das ist kacke da
kann es beim zoll landen die nächste variante ist über was wollte ich aber fuck krieg ich
gar nicht mehr zusammen was war die drei varianten genau sie verschicken aus dem eu waren lager also
sprich die die wahre ist schon in der eu und wird nach deutschland verschickt das gibt es auch dann
ist auch mit soll nichts weil innerhalb von der eu kein zoll oder sie verschicken es von china
nach spanien in die niederlande oder nach portugal oder sonst wo aber niederland ist bei aliexpress
voll angesagt ich glaube spanien macht banggood ganz gerne und sprich die schicken es von china
nach spanien und dann von spanien nach deutschland der unterschied ist dass das der letzte weg von
der eu in die eu ist und dann auch nicht beim zoll hängen bleibt damit da gibt es kein zoll
soll gibt es nur und das ist auch kein trick der irgendwie illegal wäre das ist halt gesetzlich
nun mal so soll gibt es nur wenn es direkt vom austern an euch geht das ist das was die
kakona mans nicht auf die reihe bekommen wenn ihr bei den amis was bestellt die adressieren
das immer direkt an euch und dann schicken sie es auch mit so komischen dingern wie fedex oder
sowas und dann landet es im zoll also hier ist die chance relativ gut dass das passt dass da
nix im zoll landet und bei banggood ist es ganz einfach rauszubekommen bei banggood ist es ganz
einfach rauszubekommen ob es im zoll landen kann oder nicht ich hoffe die haben das nix
geahnd am angenommen hier das da das bord ist gut so angenommen ihr wollt das ihr wollt das
kaufen sondern müsst ihr sagen ok die haben es unbenannt früher hieß das eu priority line aber
nachdem das vier bis sechs business day braucht ist es genau es kommt eh aus uk dann gibt es ok
ich habe keine ahnung wie die zoll abkommen mit mit uk jetzt sind aber ok es heißt jetzt banggood
express meinetwegen eu priority line das müsst ihr bestellen also immer wenn ihr bei banggood das
bestellt und und eu priority line gibt es zur auswahl genau wenn ihr aus china bestellt nicht
eu wahrenlage und ihr könnt eu priority line auswählen dann machen die diesen trick dass
sie das glaub über spanien oder so schicken es geht dann von china von den chinesen geht es
dann runde aus china nach spanien von spanien wird es dann an euch geschickt also eigentlich
eine richtig gute idee exzellent so und jetzt muss ich chat gucken weil ich bin überhaupt nicht
näher gekommen was ein fader erfolgreich über zoll jellyplugs zu kaufen das ist exquisite ist nicht
schlecht übrigens ja was ich euch erzählen wollte wir müssen morgen c++ machen kann
witz wir müssen morgen c++ machen ja monka giga wir müssen den strom nicht den strom zähler den
strom zähler ausleser fertig programmieren oder fertig bauen ich hoffe mal dass kopfe
morgen technisch wenn ich noch ein bisschen weiter rücken und halsübung mache das soweit
so gut ist dass das passt und ich hoffe dass ich es morgen machen kann ich habe es jetzt ich habe
es jetzt auch schon so weit zusammengebaut dass display und controller dran ist und und auch das
netzteil schon mal anschließen kann und sowas also wir müssen morgen noch die sensoren dran machen
also sprich temperatursensor luftfeuchtigkeit was ist was für ein sensor ist das luftfeuchtigkeit
temperatur luftdruck ok brauche kamen also temperatur luftfeuchtigkeitsensor den sensor
für den zähler und den sensor für den zweiten zähler das muss man morgen auch dran machen und
dann das ganze programmieren dass es ordentlich funktioniert wir machen kein c++ aufwacht stream
heute ist ja auch als freitags aufwacht stream ist sonntag wir morgen geschwandern falls das
wetter was zulässt weil das ist auch eine sache ich bin jetzt auch die letzten tage wieder ein
bisschen durch die luft laufen das hat wirklich kopf wehmäßig geholfen aber leider nicht lang
und wie machst jetzt strom 12 volt auf 5 volt converter ich hab noch nen ich hab noch nen pack
d1 mini schilds gehabt ich mach da kein d1 mini rein aber die schilds kann ich verwenden 12 volt
auf 5 volt und hab dann einen 5 volt pinn einfach den ausgang gelötet max hat corona sehr unwahrscheinlich
ja übrigens die auf youtube auf twitter die video qualität ist ja mal richtig schlecht oder ich
mein guck mal das ist der clip aus dem video aus dem stream wurde wo hier rauch rauskommt du
erkennst nichts du erkennst nichts auf twitter hat man irgendwie erkannt dass es gesmokt hat
habt ihr habt ihr rauch habt ihr rauch erkannt ich nett im ging im gegensatz wenn man hier guckt
clips smog wenn ihr hier den smog seht dann seht ihr den smog auch richtig guckt hier mal jetzt
jetzt hat hier hast du es jetzt richtig gesehen dass es geraucht hat
und ich hoffe das machen wir morgen nicht also genau skill killer ich hoffe ich hab das beantwortet
jetzt ich bin ab ich mach wie gesagt ich mach es absichtlich so ich bezahle das selbst wenn
ich ordentlich behandelt wenn will ansonsten wenn es einfach nur geht dass ich eine krankmeldung
kriege weil ich weiß es ist nichts schlimmes dann bin ich den aussatz gar nicht so schlecht
ich will das originale zulu haben für das originale zulu ja du kannst fast alle
emotes kritisch nutzen aber nur weil jetzt irgendjemand den du nicht magst was verwendet
was du auch verwendest macht dich nicht zum gleichen wie ihn weißt du also sprich das
ist das ist genau das gleiche das ist das gleiche beispiel wenn jetzt irgendwie jemand
sich hinstellt und sagt hey ich was weiß ich ich bin da und dafür so da gibt es jetzt immer
leute die sagen nein dafür darfst du nicht sein weil was weiß ich die afd beispielsweise
auch dafür ist es auch immer so ein ding darfst du jetzt nicht dafür so nur weil es
zufälligerweise was ist wurde ich auch dafür sind da frage ich mir okay aber nur weil man
zufälligerweise sachen gleich sieht macht es doch nicht zwei leute automatisch in allen
gesichtspunkten zur gleichen haben sie zu die gleiche meinung ja und das ist bei emotes
auch so zum beispiel das okay händs emote ist das beste beispiel dafür dieses ok symbol
hat weltweit 50 milliarden bedeutung ja und irgendwann bei uns steht es halt tatsächlich
eher für okay und irgendwann kam dann fortschein auf die idee hat ein bisschen rumgetrollt und
hat pippe und okay händ in verbindung gebracht mit white power so jetzt ist halt die frage
ist jetzt jeder der okay händ jemals benutzt hat automatisch für diese ganze white power
geschichte das eine mit dem anderen hat erstmal gar nichts zu tun und das schlimme ist was
die bei fortschein geschafft haben ist taucher können es auch nicht mehr verwenden die haben
das geschafft dass echte nazis das okay händ symbol in diesem kontext verwenden ich glaube
dass es neben dem pippe emote und ein paar andere dinge an sachen wo sie sich gewünscht
haben sie hätten ein bisschen weniger getrollt weil das musste erst mal schaffen von einem
fake zu was was die was wirklich rechtsextreme verwenden aber fortschein ist da eh next level
was das angeht außerdem kann man sich fragen wenn ein schwarzes emote gelöscht wird was
sagt es denn dann da drüber aus da gibt es ja nur noch weiße emote das geht ja auch
wieder nicht übrigens letztens ist mir letztens ist mir aufgefallen ist nicht eigentlich
auch billiard spielen rassistisch weil ich mein die weiße kugel wirft schwarze farbige
ins loch das ist eigentlich auch schon ganz grenzwertig billiardspielen oder außerdem
die kugeln sind auch noch ziemlich sind auch noch ziemlich rund das grenzt ja auch schon
an fat shaming also man kann was ich damit sagen will ist man kann alles sich irgendwie
zurecht drehen natürlich ist billiard nichts rassistisches aber man kann sich alles irgendwie
zurecht drehen total biscuit war kein schwarzer das ist das problem ich sehe da kein problem
ich sehe da überhaupt kein problem drin aber dieses thema ist mittlerweile so aufgeladen
die leute sind instant auf 180 ja pleck okay das das habe ich auch nie genau verstanden was da
worüber sich da aufgeregt wird aber ich muss das auch gar nicht alles verstehen ich bin
auch ich bin ehrlich gesagt ganz froh dass ich wie soll ich sagen so am aktuellen zeitgeist
nicht alles mehr nachvollziehen kann weil vieles ist echt ein bisschen bizarre geworden
beispielsweise habe ich letztes gelesen diese zwei schwestern die tennis gespielt haben
irgendwie williams sonst was die waren ziemlich gut im besten weiblichen tennis spieler oder
spielerin und die haben in dem interview gesagt sie würden also es ging irgendwie drum ob
die einen show match machen gegen gegen irgendwie weltranglisten männer oder haben die quasi
gesagt nein bloß nicht die machen uns fertig und da haben sich leute ernsthaft drüber
aufgeregt dass sie das in einem interview gesagt hat ich aber man darf nicht man darf
nicht vergessen es gibt wohl auf der welt kaum jemand der so viel expertise hat in diesem
thema wie die zwei medels und wenn die das halt zu sehen und es ist ja wahrscheinlich
auch so dass die wahrscheinlich gegen die kerle auf auf den oberen weltranglisten plätzen
nicht keine sonne sehen würden aber allein schon dass sie das ausgesprochen hat im interview
war war absolut no go da sind die leute wieder aus geflippt ohne ende skilkehler dankeschön
für den sub kupfer mann 15 monat excellent subscription die sollten sich alle mal ein
bisschen mehr an den da lai lama halten und sich erleuchten lassen da werden alle deutlich
entspannter kupfer mann dankeschön für die huge subscriptions
ja aber christoph was sagt das denn jetzt gegen den schwarz gegen den gegen den gegen
den im mod 2021
ich weiß nicht wozu man das im mod braucht wozu braucht man das salami im mod es gibt
halt auch im mods die sind jetzt vielleicht nie auf den ersten blick aber muss man sie
deswegen löschen
ja das ist das sehe ich tatsächlich auch als problem dass du kaum was verdienst an
gesetzlich versicherten ja das ist das ist das hauptsächliche problem ich glaube viele
ärzte würden sich gerne mehr um ihre patienten kümmern oder sich länger um ihre patienten
kümmern aber die kriegen kein geld dafür ja und hier bleibt nur zwei sachen übrig
entweder du machst das nicht lang oder die gehts irgendwann am arsch vorbei ja also das
würde ich immer sagen dabei sagen dass du selbst bezahlst ja bettard tritts tv beste
also ffz ich bevorzuge ja ffz aber ffz mit bettard tritts tv mit bettard tritts tv emote
kennst dich mit open office aus nee
wundert mich dass es das noch nicht gibt hide boob cam warum nicht eigentlich eine richtig
gute idee das kann man doch bestimmt mit mit künstlicher intelligenz und bildanalyse
heutzutage machen
analysiert boob cam streams und wenn es gefunden wird kommt es auf eine oplacklist darf man
ja auch nicht mal sagen auf eine sperrliste und das blendet dein addon aus das ist eigentlich
eine richtig gute idee
ja genau du musst sagen du bezahlst selbst oder bist privat versichert komm aufs gleiche
war es auch echt war gut warum nicht das sind so sachen kann das kann ich ja noch nachvollziehen
ja das ist aktueller zeitgeist da würde ich wahrscheinlich wenn ich eine firma hätte
und wüsste das kommt gut an würde ich das auch machen und da ist ja auch an sich nichts
gegen einzuwenden ja ja du kannst heute ohne probleme sogar in einer notaufnahme vier stunden
sitzen gar kein gar kein thema
ja alles gut
du weißt nicht was passiert ist heute kam eine antwort von der ihk die wollen wissen
welche werkzeuge ich in meinem projekt nutze ich habe darauf geantwortet keine sich sagen
das kann was für werkzeuge meine die programme die du verwendest um das zu erstellen oder
meinen die wirklich richtig echte werkzeuge das 20 teile gewehrer schraubendreher set
einsteller sieben moin excellent
hey max hast du eine ahnung ob es eine homepage für auftragsarbeiden von hobbyingenieuren
gibt wo fiver im zweifelsfall fiver oder wenn du dir die throne bauen lassen willst gehe
ich mal von aus da gibt es sicherlich auch die ein oder vermute ich jetzt mal ich hab
keine throne aber ich vermute mal dass es da in irgendwelchen elektronikforen auch bau
helfen angebote gibt
so
oh ja die amis kriegen das nicht auf die reihe die chinesen haben damit kein problem
sachen zu verschicken sodass es nicht beim zoll landet
am geilsten war immer noch das in casso dieser in casso laden der mir mal eine nachricht geschickt
hat ich hätte in heiligenhafen einen telefonanschluss in heiligen ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß gar
nicht wo das ist echt ist ok mittlerweile zoll technisch auch
drin das sagt ich hab oh ich hab ich hab dings ich hab controller bestellt aus uk fuck ja
aber ich hab ich gelesen genau man muss halt aufpassen wo man ist ja so andere länder andere
länder andere sitten ich muss halt ich muss halt auch gucken wie ich was verwende wenn
ich nicht irgendwo anecken will geltener danken für den sub komfort euch hatte ich
schon
oh jetzt kommt's oh nee das thema wieder ok ok letztes was ich dazu heute sag also meinst
du nicht wenn worte wortwendung und auch symbolen von rassistischen radikalen gruppen vereinbart
werden ein und immer wieder mit beabsichtigen zweideutig den hintergrund verwenden dass man
versuchen was dass man versucht zu unterbinden dem an die worte bilder im alltag einfach
selber nicht mehr gebraucht was was jeder selbst macht ist ja demjenigen selbst überlassen
sei da kein problem mir tut das nicht weh das emote nicht zu verwenden das problem was
ich dabei sehe ist wo hörst du auf wo fängst du an also ich ich erachte es für deutlich
sinnvoller ich sage die einstellung der leute versuchen zu ändern ja dass viele leute erkennen
dass was jemand anderen irgendwie beleidigt ja oder oder oder mitnimmt oder ein anderer
problem mit hat also dass man die leuten quasi mal nahe legt hey es ist keine gute
idee gewisse sachen zu verwenden dass das beleidigt mich was auch immer also die einstellung
der leute zu werden weil das problem ist wenn du ohne die einstellung der leute zu ändern
einfach worter und sachen verbietest wir reden jetzt nicht von hakenkreuz oder sowas ja dann
ist die frage wo hörste auf wo fängste an willst du dann alles was irgendwann mal oder
oder in ab wann ist häufig definiert was irgendwo irgendwann mal in einem wie auch
immer nicht gewollten kontext verwendet wird willst du das abschaffen das ist halt das
ist halt problematisch du kannst du kannst nicht alles verbieten in der regel wenn du
sachen verbietest wird sogar noch schlimmer weil sich die leute sachen nicht wegnehmen
lassen wollen und die frage ist wo wo hörste auf also wo fängste an wo hörste auf willst
du billiardspielen verbieten weil es eine weiße kugel ist und du kannst gift drauf
nehmen es gibt leute im internet die sich da dran garantiert stören und in den riesen
schittstorm auf twitter machen wenn der falsche was zu weißen und schwarzen bildertkugeln
sagt und das hört das hört halt nicht auf und du weißt nicht wo es anfängt nur wo
es aufhört deswegen die einstellung der leute zu ändern ist auf jeden meinen ansicht nach
zumindest die bessere einstellung als wild um sich sachen sachen zu verbieten und ja
das dauert natürlich ein bisschen und man sieht ja auch wie welch welchen merkwürdigen
züge manche manche also welch welch komische dimension manche sachen annimmt wie gesagt
zum beispiel ich das ist mein lieblingsbeispiel weil ich finde da wurde es total übertrieben
es gab einen riesen schittstorm weil tracer in overwatch lesbisch ist wo man sich fragt
warum ist das nicht eigentlich in der heutigen zeit was was voll in den zeitgeist passt
nein ist es nicht weil tracer ein charakter ist der explizit für das männliche auge
designed wurde da bricht es doch ab im kopf das kann es doch das kann es doch normal
denken den leuten nicht vermitteln diese denkweise das leuchtet auch nicht ein und wo fängst
er an wo hörste auf das ist das eigentliche problem dabei wenn du anfängst sachen zu
verbieten weil es irgendjemand stört du musst eher du musst eher darauf hinarbeiten die
einstellung der leute zu ändern und das ist eigentlich auch so wie die sachen klappen
ja mit mit wildem verbieten werden wir glaube ich nicht sonderlich weit kommen außer dass
es dann noch interessanter wird und viele viele leute das ganze jetzt erst recht machen
hey wäre xqc nicht für tryhard 7 gebannt geworden in overwatch ihr könnt euch vielleicht
daran erinnern xqc hat tryhard 7 gepaust in dem overleak chat als ein schwarzer zu sehen
waren oder ein pock wie es so schön heutzutage heißen wo ein farbiger schwarzer zu sehen
war und der wurde gebannt dafür daraufhin daraufhin ging tryhard 7 durch die decke vorher
hat tryhard 7 kaum jemand interessiert außer im xqc chat daraufhin hat 90 prozent der twitter
chats der twitch chats waren voll mit tryhard 7 und da kommt man letztendlich hin wenn man
einfach sachen verbietet
deswegen finde ich sachen nur weil sich ein paar leute daran stören grundsätzlich zu
verbieten nicht nicht sinnvoll wenn es was breit akzeptiertes ist was nicht ok ist und
es sogar vielleicht so gesetze gibt dass man sachen nicht verwenden darfst dann ist es
natürlich was anderes ja wir haben ganz klar gesetze hakenkreuze darfst du nicht verwenden
also ist da hat auch ruhe zu sein was bedeutet tryhard 7 das sind sieben ist so ein salutier
cruz
by the way das ist auch eine sache da bin ich auch zwiegespalten ich sehe es auch so
dass man viele sachen nicht unbedingt nicht unbedingt so gut einschätzen kann wenn man
nicht zu einer betroffenen gruppe gehört das heißt aber im umkehrschluss nicht das
jegliche meinung der jemand äußert hat zu einem thema der nicht zu einer betroffenen
gruppe gehört die automatisch ungültig ist das ist ja auch eine sache die heute ganz
gerne gemacht gemacht wird so nach dem motto wie du hast da was dazu gesagt als als als
mann als weißer mann noch noch schlimmer als alter weißer mann das ist ja prinzipiell
schon mal nicht wellet was du gesagt hast weil du gehörst ja nicht dazu so schließt
mir auch durchaus die ein oder anderen sinnvollen meinungen aus ich meine ich gehe da insofern
mit weil man sagt hey manche sachen kann man nicht nachvollziehen da gebe ich euch recht
ja also manche sachen kannst du nicht nachvollziehen also ich kann ich ich werde nicht nachvollziehen
können wie es ist als schwarze in usa zu leben das werde ich nicht nicht hinbekommen
ja aber trotzdem kann ich mir zu aktuellen themen natürlich die faktenlage angucken
und mich dazu äußern und manchmal und das darf man auch nicht vergessen und manchmal
sind beobachtung von jemanden der nicht direkt betroffen ist objektiver als von leuten die
direkt betroffen sind ja das stimmt bei aliexpress machen sie auch so machen das jetzt auch gern
wenn die was verschicken die chinesen dann hat sich letztens übrigens auch einer auf
twitter darüber aufgeregt weil ich gesagt habe die chinesen ich meine es ist aliexpress
das sind chinesen die schreiben einfach auf das paket oder diesen schein ein dollar elektronik
teile gut ist ich muss dazu sagen der friseur wird denn der nimmt gay auch als scherzhafte
beleidigung und mal ganz im ernst ich fühle mich auch nicht jedes mal drüber angegriffen
wenn einer witz über dicke macht da hätte ich echt viel zu tun man muss ein bisschen
man muss ein bisschen nicht abgehärtet werden abgehärtet werden ist das ist das fall dort
man muss ein bisschen ausgeglichener werden was das angeht jeder hat so seine macken und
seine fehler die keiner gerne hört wenn andere leute darauf rumreiten wenn ich ein bisschen
zu dick bin und leute machen witz drüber dass der max zu fett ist dann kränkt mich das
schon irgendwo aber ich würde jetzt nicht fordern man soll witz über dicke verbieten
man muss allein schon aus mentalen gesundheitlichen gründen dass man nicht durchdreht mit der
zeit im kopf muss man ein bisschen entspannter werden was diese ganze sache angeht sich
einfach nur denken leute fickt euch ja und wenn es natürlich in die strafbare ecke rein
geht dann sie dann ist es natürlich was anderes ja aber nur weil einer witz über dicke macht
in meinem bei sein muss ich muss ich da nicht auf fünf social media plattform jetzt erst
mal einen riesen fass aufmachen dass die typen entlassen gehören das ist leider das was
in einigen bereichen passiert es kann nicht sein also es kann es kann nicht sein dass
wenn wenn ich im bei sein auf der arbeit wenn jemanden witz über dicke macht und ich fühle
mich davon beleidigt das kann ich dem sagen da bin ich da bin ich bei euch ja ich kann
sagen ey finde ich einen scheiß witz oder noch besser du machst den blöden witz blöden
witz über den oder so ja aber du kannst natürlich sagen ey finde ich einen scheiß witz aber
was ich nicht okay finde ist was ich nicht okay finde ist danach zur personal abteilung
rennen und so nach dem motto alter ich poste jetzt wenn ihr den ich rausschmeißt poste
ich auf 50 social media plattform dass die und die firma fett schämen geil findet das
finde ich dann zu übertrieben das ist das was leider in einigen bereichen passiert
dass also diese shitstorm geschichte finde ich viel zu übertrieben dem wenn es dich
persönlich abfuckt kannst du das dem ruhig sagen und meinetwegen auch nicht so nett
anderweitig wäre das jetzt anderweitig wäre das jetzt man muss da man muss da natürlich
auch immer ein bisschen die die verhältnismäßigkeit und und die jeweilige sache einschätzen ja
wenn einer jetzt rum rennen und witz über dicke macht dann kann ich da drüber hinweg
sehen würde ich jetzt hätten wir beispielsweise dann dann jemand wo ich sehen würde dass
der regelmäßig den medels an bobs greift im fahrstuhl das ist wieder was anderes da
würde ich dann auch sagen ja gut da muss da halt rüber hinweg sehen ich will man muss
ein bisschen so sich auch die die verhältnismäßigkeit angucken ich kann ich wegen einer banalen
aussage den riesen shitstorm los treten und du findest heutzutage genug leute die mitmachen
damit man kann auch alle sachen irgendwie auch zusammen reißen und das ist auch eine
sache die mich nervt ja wenn es um solche themen gehen da packen da packen alle seiten
immer gleich da gleich die dicksten die dicksten geschütze aus dann schreibt einer was und
da kommt gleich einer mit der antwort ich aber die nazis haben das auch gemacht so das
fetteste geschütz was du überhaupt in deutschland rausholen kannst auch wenn es damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun hat deswegen hat keiner mehr bock über ein bisschen kontroverse themen
zu reden gerade durch dieses ganze social media shitstorm geschichte sprache war schon
immer mal klar guckt euch mal jugendsprache von heute an
das finde ich ist das wichtige ja man muss den leuten erstmal sinnvoll verklickern warum
was nicht ok ist und wenn sich das dann dadurch dass man die leute überzeugt hat ändert
ist das ok wenn du sachen verbietest hat es in der regel komplett den kontraproduktiven
effekt wie gesagt weil hat sehr viel auf twitch das beste beispiel dafür also ich bestreite
nicht dass es probleme gibt nicht nur in deutschland sicherlich weltweit wenn es um das thema
rassismus geht aber eine sache die ich finde die aktuell deutlich zu kurz kommt das ist
was was ich persönlich merke weil mit 36 also so wie ich mein leben leben leben lebe war
früher definitiv nicht allgemein akzeptiert ja und wenn ich mich heute hinstellen würde
und sage ich bin schwul würde auch kein interessieren ich finde eine sache kommt bei diesen ganzen
sachen bei den diskussionen bisschen zu kurz 2021 du konntest dich persönlich noch nie
ich rede jetzt mal von deutschland zum kürzeren der westlichen welt ja es gibt länder ist
das leider bisschen zurückgegangen du konntest dich noch nie so frei entfalten wie heute
du konntest noch nie so offen leben sich noch nie so frei persönlich entfalten wie jemals
zuvor das ist eine sache die meiner einsicht ein bisschen bisschen kurz kommt aktuell
das wird immer so getan als ist das so schlimm wie nie zuvor das stimmt nicht es ist aktuell
eine der wie soll man sagen so für persönlich einfach eines der sorgenfreisten besten zeiten
aller zeiten die wir je gehabt haben ich sage nicht dass es probleme gibt die gibt es nicht
nur hier die gibt es überall auf der welt und dass es extreme ansichten in allen richtungen
gibt es auch steht auch außer frage aber das muss man sich mal wirklich auch vor vor
augen halten dass es heutzutage schon verdammt gut ist das kommt bei den ganzen diskussionen
meiner ansicht ein bisschen kurz und dadurch es wird einfach nur extrem viel diskutiert
und es wird auch bei kleinigkeiten des riesen shitstorm fast aufgemacht und das wirkt teilweise
so extrem übertrieben man muss man muss bei diesen ganz bei diesen ganzen sachen nämlich
auch ein bisschen hingucken man darf die leute nicht zu sehr abhängen das ist nämlich auch
eine sache was weil wir verbieten alles mögliche oder wir sind dafür alles mögliche zu verbieten
passiert du verlierst die leute auf dem weg und das ist genau kontraproduktiv weil was
machen die leute dann was machen die leute die sich abgehängt fühlen bei sowas die der
meinung sind dass ihre interesse nicht mehr vertreten werden die sagen oder gehen wir
die afd wählen was ja eigentlich nicht das ziel sein kann was was man haben will
kannst du kannst du machen aber du musst dich nicht wundern wenn einer sagt du kack
spaß darf man sicherlich auch nicht sagen hier du arsch was soll der kack musste dann
auch mit klarkommen wenn du sowas erzählst ja ja so also dicke sind schwerer zu entführen
da habe ich mir doch gar keine gedanken darüber gemacht aber wenn du so dick bist dass du
nicht mal ins auto passt dann auf jeden fall bei jetzt thema fett schämen ich will jetzt
ich muss jetzt mal was sagen ich hatte mal auf der alten arbeit wo ich früher gearbeitet
und kollege der war echt schon extrem dick ich habe keine ahnung was er gewohnt hat
300 sonst oder so ich weiß ich der war aber zwei sachen die waren echt krass erstens
der hat laufende neuen büro stuhl gebraucht weil er immer die arme lehen abgesprengt hat
der hat sich da reingesetzt und nach zwei tagen war die arme lehen ab war das erste
und das nächste ist da muss ich heute noch dran denken ich bin ich ich bin vom klo gekommen
und da ist der typ auch ist der typ gerade aufs klo der musste um in dieses klo häuschen
rein zu kommen seitlich einparken also normalerweise wenn ihr aufs klo geht werdet ihr das so machen
ich geht hin ihr geht in das bad rein dann sind das so drei für drei kabinen nebeneinander
und vor den kabinen sind halt die dinge an der wand zum rein pingeln und da gehst du
kabine machst die tür auf läuft gerade rein machst die tür schließt die tür ab drehst
dich rum setzt aufs klo das ging bei dem nicht der musste hin zur kabine die tür weit aufmachen
sich zur seite drehen bauch einziehen seitlich strafen der ist gestraft ins klo rein gestraft
seit step seit step ins klo rein hat dann mit der hand die tür genommen beim rein strafen
zu gemacht mit der linken hat abgeschlossen sich dann wieder rumgetreten aufs klo gesetzt
also muss er vorstellen der kerner war schon so dick dass dass der mal ins klo gepasst
hat das war echt heftig huge mechanics das war echt das war echt hart ja zapcon ich weiß
auch nicht wie ich zu dem thema jetzt gekommen bin ich will jetzt aber eigentlich mit dem
thema nicht movement gott mit dem thema nicht weitermachen das ist nicht gut aber man muss
auch man muss halt auch mal gucken in welchem ausmaß das wirklich der fall ist systematisch
heißt ja nicht nur weil zwei leute mal was gemacht haben
ich mache auch dumme witze über dicke und leute ich höre zwar immer als bin ich ultra
fett aber ich komme wenigstens auch ins klo aber ich bin auch definitiv nicht normalen
gewicht ich habe mich doch mal gewogen im stream wir haben sogar mal bmi ausgerechnet
im stream wo ich die wlan wage hatte
wo ist das problem man ist halt was man ist ich bin halt nun mal auch weißer alter mann
was soll ich denn dagegen machen außer man ist mich ja manche sachen sind halt so und
es ist ja auch nichts schlimmes ok hey thema verschwörungstheorien muss ich jetzt nicht
anfangen die hast du die wage geflasht nee die geht so über wlan ohne ohne heimzufung
ich habe letztens ein video gesehen über flat earth geschichten und da hat so ein flat earth
typ hat 10.000 euro 10.000 euro angeboten wenn man ihm widerlegt dass flat earth halt nicht
stimmt er hätte mal besser das umgedrehte machen soll 10.000 euro wäre beweis das stimmt
und es haben so viele leute bewiesen hat kein einzigen bezahlt und was also meine lieblings
meine lieblingsverschwörungstheorie ist ja ist ja nach wie vor dass die internationale
raumstation unter wasser ist das ist meine persönliche lieblingsverschwörungstheorie
also der exen mensch bodyguard von obama der ist auch nicht schlecht aber meine lieblingsverschwörungstheorie
ist dass die es ist unter den nicht es es ist der microsoft webserver es ist internet
space station dass sie unter wasser ist und man sieht angeblich auf videos ab und zu die
wasser blasen und eine sache bei the way wenn irgendjemand sagt wenn irgendjemand sagt die
mondlandung ist gefakt das kommt alles aus dem computer ich zeige euch jetzt den besten
gegenbeweis für ich hoffe ich finde das video ich zeige jetzt den besten gegenbeweis für
dass die mondlandung definitiv nicht aus dem computer kommen kann so das ist eine CGI animation
von 1974 sieht das auch nur entfernt so aus als könnte man mit dieser technik eine komplette
mondlandung faken eindeutig oder fotorealistisch illuminati am start die nasa war einfach schon
40 jahren genau das ist das erste 3d model das video das video habe ich eigentlich gemeint
wo sie wo sie die wo sie die animierte hand zeigen und sowas ich war die mondlandung war
1660 1969 alter das da ist CGI von 1972 ich meine da muss die nasa ganz schön viele ganz
schön viele super computer haben um das besser hinzukriegen
also ich sehe in zulu kein klares zeichen der sklavenzeit ich finde man kann es echt
übertreiben zulu ist ein emote von total biscuit was man schwarz gefärbt hat so und
dass das zulu genau und dass das zulu heißt kommt ich glaube sogar aus forsen stream der
mal irgendeinen pastor entdeckt hat der zulu heißt und selbst und selbst wenn es nicht
so wäre also jetzt das total biscuit emote war schwarz gefärbt ist in irgendeiner art
und weise mit mit mit sklavenhaltung da in verbindung zu bringen also das ist finde ich
jetzt schon ein bisschen bisschen weiter geholt ja hier kann man das meme nachlesen ja und
da ist jetzt das eigentliche problem wie bei dem okay hand symbol was machst du jetzt
wenn ein paar leute anfangen in dem fall was fortschreiten und haben damit rumgetrollt
mittlerweile verwenden ich direkt rechtsextreme das okay hand symbol was machst du jetzt das
ist echt schwierig aber was machst du jetzt wo fängst du an mit die sachen verbieten
und wo nicht weil sagen wir mal so das okay hand symbol ist vollkommen etabliert im sprachgebrauch
von ganz vielen ländern und bedeutet da nix nix nix böses ja bei uns taucher verwenden
für uns das eher okay will man das jetzt verbieten weil das quasi nach fortschreiten
getrolle jetzt nachträglich auch ein paar rechtsextreme aufgegriffen haben genauso
wie pepe frosch
okay also ich muss jetzt mal in den chat langsam durch durch bekommen es kommt gar nichts anderes
mal ankommen ja gut vielleicht kannst du komplett vergessen aber ich muss euch sagen obamas
bodyguard ist auch nicht schlecht obama obama exen ane moment lizard bodyguard wo ist das
video das war das beste was heißt exen mensch auf englisch das war das beste video obamas
bodyguard ist ex das kommt auch nah dran an gute verschwörungstheorie das war schon fortschreiten
das war obama da hat irgendein typ ohne haare stand stand hinter obama und haben die leute
gesagt meiner reptiloid genau obama reptiloid gibt es das noch keine ahnung zumindest da
gab es ein bodyguard der stand hinter obama und übel schlechte auflösung und da haben
die leute gesagt das ist ein exen mensch wisst ihr wisst ihr wie die auf die idee gekommen
sind dass der obamas bodyguard ein exen mensch ist weil in dem video angeblich die augen
seitlich zugehen und nicht von oben nach unten exen mensch konform auf einem 300 mal 300
pixel video was sie mit bill gates haben verstehe ich auch nicht bill gates hat nur wirklich
mit seinem geld versucht zumindest einiges gutes zu bewirken dass er nicht irgendwie
der wie nennt man das so der samariter ist und quasi alles nur für den guten zweck macht
sollte auch klar sein aber was haben die eigentlich alle gerade gegen bill gates ja genau das
militär konnte schon 1900 bevor es computer gab die mondlandung nachmachen easy ja das
kommt aber mondlandung CGI finde ich immer geil
das kann sein ja aber da wurde ja auch nix CGI da wurde ja auch noch noch echt noch
echt gefilmt ja und da sachen zu faken in dem umfang
den mensch konform ok das jetzt letzte was ich habe das ich will das thema sich zu sehr
aus ausweiten ich kann ich verstehe ich verstehe was du meinst ja und das ist sicherlich auch
ein wichtiger punkt sich um so was gedanken zu machen aber so einfach ist das halt nicht
was ist denn zum beispiel wenn ich oder wenn jemand nen doomfist cosplay macht doomfist
ist ne ist ein overwatch held stell dir mal vor du bist so ein weißbrot wie ich und spielst
gerne doomfist und machst nen doomfist cosplay das dann auch was verwerfliches weil ich mich
schwarz anmale der kontext macht es aus finde ich und ich kann jetzt ehrlich gesagt an dem
zu null emote von total biscuit einfach nur durch die pure existenz dieses emotes nix
verwerfliches kennen erkennen wenn dieses emote permanent auf twitch für klar rassistische
sachen verwendet worden wäre da wünscht ja wahrscheinlich sogar mitgehen und sagen
es ist gar schlechte idee das zu entfernen aber der kontext macht ja es gab eine blizzard
bann wusste ich noch nicht würdest du nicht machen ok aber würdest du dass du das ist
ja vollkommen ok ich würde mich auch nicht als du festverkleiden du warst nebenbei aber
stell dir mal vor irgendjemand verkleidet sich als doomfist das macht den doch nicht
zum rassist weil er sich als du bist vielleicht ist du fest immer guck mal du fest ist wenn
du fest sein lieblingscharakter ist der kontext macht halt ne das ist das ist hier bei mir
im chat glücklicherweise schon weil wir wissen der chat der chat ist big brain der chat ist
ja aber gerade auf social media nein gerade auf social media interessiert es da keiner
für cute chat soll jetzt aber auch gut aber mich jetzt die natur auslassen ssd das rickrolls
wieso kopierst du im einzelnen buchstaben weil ich das gerne mache
wenn es an mir geht kannst du das machen aber es ging jetzt nicht um tupac es ging es ging
jetzt um den schwarzen charakter in dem fall wie gesagt der kontext macht also ich kann
er erst mal jetzt nichts nichts verwerfliches dran erkennen wenn jemand sagt hey ich bin
cosplayer dumm ist es mein lieblingscharakter oder verkleidet sich als dumm fest erklärt
mir was da dran verwerfliches excellent 2 mil leider nicht guck mal leute es ist es
leider am am abkacken was aber auch zu erwarten war weil der youtube algoritmus damals einfach
nur scheiße gebaut hat und ich habe extra schon titel genommen wo die leute draufklicken
genau genau das ist auch so was ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht was hat er hat ja sogar gesagt
jimmy hendricks war sein war sein großes idol und er hat sich als jimmy hendricks verkleidet
so was ist deine bank dem öffentlichen dienstsektor zugeordnet
was habe ich mit der musik los das hört ja übelst heroisch an hier grad final bowser
also wir können du kannst das nie für andere leute entscheiden ob die sich durch irgendwas
angegriffen fühlen oder nicht wie willst du das jetzt könnte ich irgendwie einer durch
all durch alles angegriffen fühlen aber wenn sich wirklich einer dadurch angegriffen fühlt
dass jemand sich als dass jemand dumm fest cosplay der nicht schwarz ist und sich halt
nur als dumm fest verkleidet wenn es sich einer wirklich dadurch angegriffen fühlt
dann würde ich gerne mal die erklärung wissen was ihn daran so abfuckt also die erklärung
würde mich echt interessieren wo ich einfach was was stört ihn da dran
oder das beste das ist bowser galaxy generate generator zu mindestens ich will eine sache
zum schluss noch mal sagen ich bin froh dass jeder aktuell seine eigene meinung haben darf
finde ich ist super geschichte und dementsprechend kann das auch gerne jeder so sehen wie er
will ja und exzellent ja das ist offensichtlich troll aber in der heutigen zeit muss aufpassen
mit solchen aussagen sonst gleich tos angesagt genau das sehe ich aus so common sense deswegen
sag ich die sollen alle mal dem dalai lama folgen bolgo pochamp naja dass du am start
bist die soll die sollen alle mal dem dalai lama folgen und sich ein bisschen erleuchten
lassen dann sind die auch dann werden die leute auch alle ein bisschen entspannter aber man
sollte nicht automatisch immer das schlimmste in was rein interpretieren was einer sagt
also man sollte nicht gleich von der schlimmsten intention ausgehen wenn einer was sagt ich
glaube so der skill sich in andere leute zumindest ein bisschen rein versetzen zu können ist
eines der wichtigsten dinger die man so haben kann ich weiß sage ich als jemand der menschen
nicht ab kann ich bei der way ich meine damit alle menschen vollkommen egal aus dem aus
der aus dem gesicht kann es kann schon mal gar rassistisch sein weil ich mag kein egal
ob schwarz oder weiß ich mag einfach gar keine menschen ja ja aber das sage ich als
jemand der wie gesagt keine keine menschen mag aber sich manchmal ein bisschen in die
anderen leute rein zu versetzen hilft schon mal und was auch hilft ist meine nacht drüber
schlafen bevor man sich wahnsinnig über was aufregt ist auch eine sache die hilft ein
unglaublich entspannter zu sein und dem dalai lama folgen auf twitter beste so also leute
ich muss sagen kopf weh ist immer noch am start aber verträglich gerade ja gibt es
also ich nicht aber meine mutter hat nen termin in glaub drei wochen oder so übrigens habt
ihr das gelesen dass die dass die ganzen impf impfgeschichten sich jetzt weiter verzögern
irgendwie anstatt anfang april mitte april und ich war aus logistik ist nicht so unbedingt
ihre musser diszipliner
spiegel
kurz was gucken
ähh
alter mein avira spackt rum auf dem zweiten rechner ähh
ich hab mich schon gewundert auf dem zweiten rechner war grad ein terminalfenster auf einfach
einfach so
und ich wusste nicht wo es herkommt bin ich jetzt festgestellt es kommt vom avira
ja ich habe auf dem zweiten rechner immer noch avira ich weiß nicht warum eigentlich
eigentlich könnte ich den scheiß mal deinstallieren ey ohne mist gibt es überhaupt keinen sinn
hat übrigens hab ich euch erzählt ich hab fast mal einen 3d drucker geschrottet also
den da ja zumindest dachte ich dass ich den fast geschrottet hab und zwar ähm ich hab
was gedruckt man sieht schon das druckbett hat eben ein bisschen gelitten ähm das druckbett
hat wie gesagt ein bisschen gelitten und ich hab was gedruckt und hab festgestellt oh
mist ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher warum aber ich hab's abgebrochen ich hab's abgebrochen
ich hab's abgebrochen weil noch weil noch rückstände vom vorherigen druck waren so
hab ich abgebrochen bin dann mal runtergegangen was zu trinken holen als hochgekommen bin
hat der drucker abgebrochen aber die düse und das war es raus das war fest und der druckkopf
hing auf der platte fest weil da ist material noch drin gewesen das material ist hart geworden
und ich hab das erst nicht gesehen und ich bin im ich bin im webinterface hingegangen
hab gesagt drucker fahr dich wieder in neutrale position und auf einmal kommt ein riesen lärm
hier aus meinem technikraum und ich so fuck alter was ist jetzt los es hat sich angehalten
ein bisschen presslufthammer mir so und dann bin ich da reingegangen das war mein 3d drucker
der ist da hier unten dieses gummiband das hat so einen schutz gegen gegen zu weit hinter
also wenn es fest hängt dass es dann trüberspringt über das zahnrad quasi ab einer gewissen
stärke wo dran gezogen wird und das war dieses das war dieses dieses gummiband was permanent
das zahnrad hinten gesprungen ist und dann habe ich gesehen dass eben der druckkopf
sich nicht bewegen konnte weil der auf der noch mit druckresten auf der platte fest
hängen da hab ich da hab ich echt monka est wie hat der drucker gemacht ungefähr so
ungefähr so hat der drucker sich angehört zumindest er ist nicht rip ich musste das
aufheizen und dann konnte ich mit der spachtel weg machen und gut ist und chopper gunner
nicht chopper gunner war eher und ac130 wäre eher das ist ac130 ja und chopper gunner ist
wie gesagt excellent das muss man jetzt mal geklärt haben chopper gunner mw2 sound passt
auf die quali die quali alter ja hab ich noch gesagt
so und ac130 ist eindeutig du hast die minigun und du hast du hast den großen mörser und
du hast diese diese 40 millimeter dinger ja genau so so sieht es aus
ja wie gesagt 3d drucker fast geschrottet
so also gibt es sonst noch irgendwelche richtigen dinger was ich erzählen muss und zwar lass
mal überlegen ach wisst ihr was mir einfällt hat jemand von euch der ahnung kennt jemand
nen heizlüfter mit wifi gibt es da was gutes warum ich frage ist folgendes äh warum ich
frage ist folgendes also ich habe im partner heizlufter wenn es mal schnell warm werden
muss und ich habe mir jetzt überlegt also was ich aktuell habe ist ich habe einfach
so eine zwischensteckdose dass ich das einschalten kann übers wlan ich will keine abgeschnitten
ich will irgendwas was über sich offene schnittstellen steuern das gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht von
show me wahrscheinlich haben die sowas ah yes aliexpress
jupin mini heizlüfter desktops die desktops sonne die chinesen kinaware ok ok mal amazon
gucken die m das liegt daran das ist nur so ein über brand die die bestehen aus ganz
vielen untergeordneten firmen also nur weil das show mir drauf steht ist das nicht automatisch
der gleiche laden
heizlüfter von aliexpress ja eigentlich eher nicht elektro rasierer
ne von aliexpress bestellte kein so viel zumindest ich hab sie aktuell so ich hab ne zwischensteckdose
dass ich das übers wlan übers wlan schalten kann und ich habe mir zu überlegt was echt
cool wäre wenn ich das ding nicht nur übers wlan schalten könnte ein und aus sondern
auch die temperatur einstellen kann oder zumindest die stufen einstellen kann am besten wäre
natürlich lüfter und stufen einstellbar was kann der denn was kann der denn dieses
teil show me jupin aber das ist das das ist so richtig krasse china ding das will ich da
habe ich angst dass aufs ohne auf sich den bahn einzuschalten desktop sonne ok wir müssen
die sprache auf jeden fall mal auf englisch stellen ok moment
heat wifi fx was für ein ding
was für ein teil
das ist kein heizlüfter das ist eher eher eine heizung was kann das teil denn
counter top ich nein nein nein leute leute ich darf da nicht in versuchung geraten mir
bei aliexpress ein heizlüfter zu bestellen da brennt mir das haus ab das mache ich nicht
das mache ich nicht nee darf ich nicht mit anfangen nee nee das bringt nichts das bringt
nichts was ich meine ist ich würde gern die die am liebsten würde ich gerne die temperatur
einstellen können weil es ist es ist so ich beschreibe euch das mal kurz warum ich das
haben will also ich möchte dass ich möchte das folgenden kund haben wenn ich morgens
aufs klo muss dann ist die heizung noch nicht an ich habe da zwar jetzt mittlerweile so
ein so ein so ein thermostat dran aber die heizung geht auch erst ab 7 so richtig so richtig
hoch dann also von von der kellerheizung ja so und wenn ich morgens mal aufs klo muss
und es dauert länger als 20 sekunden dann mache ich den heizlüfter an mittlerweile
ist es easy mittlerweile habe ich da den nfc tag das heißt wenn ich den lüfter das heißt
wenn ich mein handy dabei habe dann kann ich per nfc tag wie man hier in den videos
sieht das nicht funktioniert aber wenn es funktioniert dann sieht man das kann ich
da ist der heizlüfter da kann ich mit meinem handy an den nfc tag gehen und alter warum
ist twitter video so kacke guck da dran gehalten zack dann geht an und noch mal dran gehalten
dann geht er wieder aus das ist ja schon nice das ist ja schon nice so aber was nicht gut
funktioniert ist ich kann nicht einstellen wie warm der wird und wenn ich auf dem klo
sitze dann wird es mir nach drei vier minuten zu warm deswegen würde ich gerne den nicht
einfach ausschalten sondern den weiter laufen lassen aber weil wenn ich den ausschalte dann
kommt so die kälte vom restlichen raum wieder so und am liebsten würde ich den weiter pusten
lassen aber die temperatur runter regeln beziehungsweise vielleicht sogar einfach nur auf kalt schalten
und dann wieder hoch schalten hat er keinen regler die der regler von heizlüftern ist
in der regel der regel ist in der regel nur dafür da dass man eine temperatur einstellt
wo er dann ausgeht also sprich der heizlüfter pustet auf der stufe wo man eingestellt hat
wenn er über eine gewisse temperatur ist schaltet er sich aus aber ich will ja nicht
dass er sich ausschalten er soll weiter pusten aber mit weniger temperatur das heißt ich
bräuchte einen heizlüfter wo man die stufen über wlan steuern kann ich selbst bauen
will das nicht ich könnte sicherlich irgendwie einen controller oder so da einbauen aber
ich will eigentlich nicht an meinem heizlüfter rumdoktern ne wand heizlüfter ich brauche
es auf die erdstelle kann weil hier bei dem ist es ja auch so auf alter twitter video
komm mal please please please so guck hier oben die temperatur die die einstellen kann
stellt er nicht wirklich die temperatur ein das stellt einen schwellenwert ein ab wann
er ausgeht ein dimmer vor den heizlüfter das ist eine ziemlich coole idee den dimmer
vor den heizlüfter du meinst dass der einfach anstatt 2000 watt zu ziehen dann nur noch
1000 zieht kann man den heizlüfter mit dem dimmer geht das was macht denn den dimmer
limitiert ein dimmer wieviel wieviel ampere drüber gehen können oder oder was oder oder
oder macht ein dimmer oder macht es ein dimmer über die spannung weil über die spannung
wird nicht funktionen da wird das gerät wahrscheinlich einfach nicht laufen ah ein dimmer macht
ein dimmer ganz schnell an und aus oder wie na gut mit mit geregelter spannung ich glaube
nicht dass das ding überhaupt funktionieren wird mit mit viel weniger als 230 volt heizlüfter
regeln und schau da ein zu regeln oder pwm die leute die leute haben big brain idee ne alter
ey dies das das microcontroller forum das ist ein das ist mit eines der unfreundlichsten
platze im internet was es gibt also ich habe mich da nie angemeldet weil es so viele spasten
sind außerdem muss ich sagen mittlerweile kenne ich mich mit dem ganzen kram vor allem
was die programmierseite angeht doch recht passabel aus ich würde mal sagen wahrscheinlich
sogar besser als die meisten im forum weil die tipps die du da teilweise liest sind
echt absoluter witz und dann dann diese typischen forums diskussionen immer wisst ihr was mich
an forren also gerade an deutschsprachigen forren aber sind in deutschsprachigen forren
vielleicht reicht das eigentlich alle möglichen forren nervt es geht jemand in den forum und
fragt was zum beispiel irgendjemand hat sich ein gerät gekauft und will wissen er hat
sich ein smartes klo gekauft und will wissen wie man die temperatur auf halb so viel stellt
wie werksmäßig eingestellt weil es ihm zu warmer bobs ist so dass diese frage stellt
er im forum und wisst ihr und wisst ihr was die erste was die erste antwort im forum
ist ja ok leute ihr habt recht diese fragen kommen auch aber die erste antwort im forum
ist warum will man dann so was machen beschreibe doch erstmal ein anwendungsszenario warum
möchtest du das überhaupt machen und dann gibt es die nächste forren die nächste stufe
in forums diskussion der derjenige beschreibt das und dann gibt es also entweder derjenige
beschreibt das gut sodass man es versteht und es gibt keine antwort drauf weil die
leute keine ahnung haben oder was meine absoluten lieblinge im forum sind jemand antwortet ja
beschreib doch dein problem mal etwas genauer dass wir dir besser helfen können und dann
kommt als antwort nicht was hilfreiches sondern bitte bitte benutze die korrekte kod formatierung
stecks oder irgendwie sowas du hast da noch ein fehler in der dritten zeile bei den kod
formatierung stecks so kann ich dir nicht helfen so kann das doch keiner lesen hier
das sind das sind die besten deswegen beteilige ich mich nicht in forren forren ist ein riesen
sammelsurium für wichtig tour einfach nur leute dies können sind selten in forren ganz
selten so und als nächstes kommt dann die antworten so nach dem motto hast du schon
mal die suchfunktion verwendet ach das ist er forren echt komplett krab auf reddit ist
es ja ähnlich ja auf reddit ist es ähnlich und reddit hat reddit hat noch eine sache die
mich nervt und zwar ich weiß ich ich habe heute schon 580.000 auf mein twitter verlinkt
aber reddit hat eine sache die mich nervt
in the app ist es available in the app aber nicht im browser
nicht im browser das das nervt mich hey leute ich brauch jetzt kein backseat chat ich weiß
was ich machen kann dass es funktioniert
ich weiß dass ich machen kann ich weiß auch dass ich mich einloggen kann ich weiß dass
ich alternative reader apps verwenden kann dass ich meinen user agent umstellen kann
ich will gar nicht ich will einfach dass ein forum im browser funktioniert
kann doch nicht sein archforum weiß ich nicht ob das so schlimm ist aber das archwiki ist
gut
das das ist das nicht ausgedacht das war legit so oder es war bei uns eine veranstaltung
auf der arbeit und wir sollten in eine umfrage reintun wir haben so ein online umfragetool
da sollten wir reinschreiben was ist das erste an was ihr bei cloud denkt und ich hab mir
gedacht du machst jetzt mal ein gag draus und ich hab poggers reingeschrieben in diese
online umfrage und was ist das erste was der typ vorliest poggers das war das erste war
dass ich poggers live auf einer 100 mann veranstaltung auf der arbeit gehört hat von jemand gesagt
der nicht ich ist
der hat ernsthaft vorgelesen was ok was ist das erste was ich an cloud denke achja ich
sehe ja schon poggers ich sehe ja schon poggers hat er vorgelesen
er hat es auch noch cool ausgebrochen hat poggers poggers wieder poggers der wusste was das
ist der typ der das vorgelesen hat hat mich echt hat mich echt überrascht
er kannte den ausdruck ja ja
ja aber das nervt mich an das nervt mich an voren wirklich also wahnsinn ja so viel
zum thema heizlüfter dass die telekom mit poggers wirkt ja wir habt ja das kann schon
passieren das ist wirklich das beste ja es ist unglaublich wie viel hilfreiche sache
man im archviki findet was im archviki habe ich letztens fast geguckt zu wo ich echt überrascht
war dass es drinne steht ich weiß nicht mal irgendwas zu was war das wollte ich jetzt
mal zeigen dass stehen da stehen die echte obskursten dinger drinne im archviki aber
also das ist nicht nur für archlinux zu gebrauchen das kannst du dir auch sachen für ubuntu
rausziehen und sowas aber es ist wirklich unscheiß dass das archviki linux technisch ist eins
der besten sachen die es gibt echt so in dem archforum ja ok das dann gehst du ins manjaro
forum manjaro forum darfst du auch als noob fragen und um was gehts die basics die basics
ist delphi eine gute programmiersprache zum anfang in der heutigen zeit nicht mehr delphi
ist von demjenigen mitentwickelt worden der auch sie scharp gemacht hat wenn ich jetzt
nicht das genau dass das sie scharp tut und da war auch chefarchitekt davor für delphi
also der typ hat ahnung und hat sie scharp designed ich würde ganz ehrlich wenn du in
dieser richtung was machen willst guck dir sie scharp an da kannst du auch wenn du dich
damit auskennst auch letztendlich alles machen auf fast jeder plattform aber ich würde zum
einstieg tatsächlich mittlerweile java script im browser empfehlen einfach weil du direkt
siehst was was passiert und man heute um ein bisschen frontend nie vorbei kommt keine chance
mehr alternativ kannst du auch mit paisten wunderbar anfangen gerade wenn du vielleicht
ein bisschen was richtung ai und machine learning machen willst aber ich finde von multifunktionalste
programmiersprache also nee nee nicht multifunkt darf man ja nicht sagen aber so die allroundigste
programmiersprache dies aktuell gibt finde ich so ich weiß ich bin sie scharp fände
ich ist tatsächlich sie scharp du kannst desktop anwendung machen server anwendung machen
du kannst mobile geschichten machen du kannst das backend für webseiten machen du kannst
juridisch sogar es im browser verwenden mit den neuesten sachen also es gibt fast nichts
außer vielleicht bootloader was du in sie scharp dort net nicht machen kannst und auch
cross platform ist finde ich noch mit am einfachsten gelöst bei go ist es ein bisschen problematisch
sachen zu cross kompilen gerade wenn du cc interfaces brauchst sowas das ist in dort
net echt easy kann man auch hafnium exploits damit schreiben wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
ja und bei so viel exploit sachen da wahrscheinlich c immer noch scheint und meinetwegen auch
c++ aber das kannst du potenziell auch mit sie scharp machen aber manche sachen sind
halt mit direktem rumsauen im speicher besser warum empfiehlst du cobalt eigentlich als
einstieg was cobalt was zum teufel ist cobalt ovo hab ran mitbekommen ja ja gut wenn es
nur wenn es nur zum zum werbung machen in der prog in in der in der bewerbung ist da
kannst du das reinschreiben also ich würde auf jeden fall nicht verschweigen in der bewerbung
wenn es ein pluspunkt ist was nicht zu erzählen was ein pluspunkt ist für dich wäre ja blöd
was nein wir haben abgestimmt keck keck keck weihnachten bleibt bis weihnachten drinnen
und an weihnachten kommt das kommt das andere keck ich mache an osten auch mal eine neue
umfrage ok wann ist an osten osten ist doch bald ist doch nicht ok in einem monat in einem
monat in einem monat frage ich noch mal ob wir den mützen den weihnachtsmützen keck
weihnachten wollen oder den anderen keck weihnachten falls ich vergesse immer mich
dran doch ich finde es sinnvoll mit javascript zu starten warum findest du es nicht sinnvoll
ich habe früher auch immer andere sachen empfohlen hab gesagt ja überleg dir mal was du machen
willst vielleicht fängst du lieber mit python oder mit zisha oder teilweise ruby ruby ist
ja auch eine super sprache zum einstieg aber was ich halt das schöne finde an javascript
ist leute die neu anfangen die sind auch relativ schnell demotiviert weil es halt langweilig
ist hallo welt kommando zeile zu machen und webseite ist was wo du eh nicht dran vorbei
kommst und wo du halt direkt siehst dass was passiert weil sonst hast du das problem instant
was mache ich denn jetzt eigentlich so nach dem motto ich habe mir jetzt ein zisha tutorial
durchgelesen was mache ich denn jetzt eigentlich und und mit webseiten ist es relativ easy
webseiten ideen haben haben die leute ganz viele aber wenn einer einen basic python tutorial
gemacht hat und sagt ja ok und was kann ich jetzt damit wirklich machen also was was mache
ich denn jetzt für eine erste anwendung dann dann hängt es bei den leuten und die sagen
dann fällt denen nicht wirklich was ein und mit webseiten ist es halt einfach da baust
dir irgendwas also ich denke einfach am besten ist das was dich motiviert beiden dabei zu
bleiben und nachdem du eh nicht an frontend sachen vorbei kommst ist das auch gar nicht
verkehrt und so schlimm ist javascript mittlerweile gar nicht mehr ich muss ehrlich sagen und
ich würde auch gar nicht mit typescript am anfang mit dabei packen sondern wirklich
mal einfach nur einfach nur javascript das nicht so viel verwirrend ist deswegen ich
finde es ich finde es sinnig ja das stimmt ja aber die wenigsten die anfangen frisch
zu programmieren wollen scientific computing machen das sage ich ja wenn du genau schon
weißt was du machen willst dann ist was anderes aber die meisten sagen hey ich würde mir
gerne einfach mal einfach mal ein bisschen gucken bisschen so die die füße nass kriegen
oder hände nass machen wir wie nennt man es richtig ihr wisst was ich meine nasse finger
irgendwie einfach mal so ein bisschen ein bisschen sich das ganze angucken und so schlimm
finde ich ja was gibt gar nicht ich meine es hat durchaus viele schwachsinnigen sachen
aber im großen und ganzen ist es eigentlich ok die finger dreckig man das meine ich nicht
wie halt wie nennt man das noch mal sprichwörtlich wenn man einfach mal eine sache kurz ausprobiert
so ein bisschen die ich weiß nicht wie gesagt ich finde javascript mittlerweile gar nicht
mal so übel ja ich gebe ich dir prinzipiell schon recht aber das was hilft die leute dabei
aber bei der stange zu halten finde ich ist wichtiger ja ein bisschen ins kalte wasser
so ja das könnte man das nennen genau dass die leute bei der sache bleiben weil es ist
ja wunderbar wenn die sprache einfacher zu lernen ist und schöner und sonst was aber
was bringt es dir wenn du wenn du dir die ersten drei tutorial kapitel durchgelesen
hast und dann und dann sagt so jetzt mache ich was und dann stehst du vor der frage
auf was mache ich denn ja für großartige dinge reicht so nicht aber was mache ich jetzt
mit javascript hast du halt das problem nicht webseiten mäßig findet sich immer irgendwas
wo man sich tritt austoben kann aus dem siehst du auch gleich was und viele leute leute finden
es sicherlich motivieren da man ein bisschen was grafisches zu sehen ist als wenn halt
konsole am start ist gar nicht gibt es doch schon genug du kannst fast alles in jeder
programmier sprache bauen ja manche sachen liegen halt manchen sprachen besser und ich
finde halt sie ist super allround was das angeht du hast in wenigen bereichen würde
ich jetzt sagen ist es irgendwo so das beste schlechthin aber es ist überall bei 95 prozent
und das macht es halt gut und die sprache an sich ist auch echt angenehm
ja so siehts aus ohne ein bisschen frontend kommst du nicht kommst du nicht hin außerdem
darf man ja nicht vergessen dass auch viele backend sachen mittlerweile javascript sind
warum auch immer aber es ist so ich bin ja da ich bin ja da kein großartiger fan von
aber man muss halt sagen dass gerade wie viele packages und sachen es für node gibt dies
vielleicht nicht für andere sachen gibt sondern der qualität für andere sachen gibt sicherlich
in anwendungsgrund warum man das auch im backend verwenden will und gerade wenn man javascript
man ist warum nicht aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht warum node so toll ist das ist
das node eine super sache ist für frontend tools also nicht im frontend zu verwenden
sondern für tools um frontend zu entwickeln das verstehe ich ja aber auf dem server node
ich meine ich verstehe es ich meine mit express so was zu machen in fünf zeilen das ist easy
ich bin kein großartiger node fan muss ich ehrlich sagen jemand schon mal multithreading
gemacht in node ich weiß die node fans sagen braucht man nicht weil event loop aber das
einer schließt das andere ja nicht aus ich glaube ich bin so ziemlich das gegenteil
ich habe den discord im letzten video gepostet vielleicht sind mal ein paar leute reingekommen
genau wenn man nämlich schon weiß was man machen will dann ist natürlich super sich
das passende dafür auszuziehen ich habe es beispielsweise auch bei meiner webcam anwendung
gemacht ich habe die web rtc sache in go programmiert das war der grund der auffänger warum ich
schon ein bisschen go gelernt habe weil es die beste web rtc library backend technisch
für go gab und ich habe gemerkt dass c interop und go nicht füreinander gemacht ist also
es geht aber google denkt sich da stecken wir keine arbeit rein und go also go hat auch
ganz ganz ganz komische dinger ja zum beispiel die standard collection klassen die sind ja
nicht existent also die gibts aber die können nix dass es keine generics gibt aber die standard
also dann auch diese dann auch diese diese go philosophie wer brauchen einen filter macht
eine schleife und sowas also aber go wirkt bei mir an vielen stellen wie so ein typisches
google produkt an den stellen wo es mal anstrengend wäre die sachen ordentlich zu machen lässt
man es bleiben ich mag go nicht wirklich aber es geht es geht also das ist eine sprache
die würde ich benutzen wenn es sich anbietet das ist kein c++ c++ mache ich ja echt einen
riesen bogen drum wenn es nicht anders geht was geht eigentlich beim friseur der da streamt
ein bisschen ab und zu ja ich gehe auch gleich ins bett das stimmt ja das das das ist es
wahrscheinlich auch ja das ist wahrscheinlich auch es gibt halt viele sachen die spielen
gut zusammen beispielsweise wenn man craft ql verwenden will apollo im backend apollo
im vorderen das er hat schon ist sicherlich ganz nice ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
weil du manche models frontend backend gleichzeitig verwenden kannst ja ich glaube aber ja es
liegt hauptsächlich daran dass viele leute die halt gut javascript frontend machen dann
auch mal irgendwie so ein halbwegs laufiges backend ganz gut hinbekommen ich meine das
note ökosystem ist auch echt riesig groß man viele ab viele mp packages sind halt keck
wade am besten das beste npm package ist immer noch leute beste npm package das das
braucht man unbedingt als package also das muss eine eigene library sein unbedingt das
ist es absolut unvorstellbar das direkt mit bordmittel einer programmiersprache zu machen
festzustellen ob eine zahl gerade oder ungerade ist also also da brauchst du schon eine library
für
ja ist hart ne ja man kann das mit modulo machen man kann das auch irgendwie mit bidshift
machen ich glaube rauszubekommen ob eine zahl gerade oder ungerade ist gibt es bestimmt
auch 30 varianten ein modulo ist das das offensichtlichste ich glaube du kannst auch irgendwie bidshiften
und dann irgendwie und mit einem und noch mit einer und operation irgendwie noch machen
aber ja aber sagen wir mal so selbst wenn man das nicht machen möchte an den stellen
da kann man sich eine funktion machen die halt return drin hat ja wir gucken uns mal
den source code davon schnell an wie groß ist in der index oh huge library also dafür
lohnt sich das schon mal
oh chat exquisite chat der chat ist wieder wahnsinn hier was wir für leute am start haben
in also er hat in seiner bachelorarbeit habe ich damals ein modell für die emittierung
von verschränkten fotonen erstellt da ich das analytisch nicht lösen konnte habe ich
das dann in peißen simuliert das ist so das typ sichere für die theoretik excellent excellent
big brain time massive hätte ich auch so gemacht hätte ich auch so gemacht wie denn auch sonst
ja wir haben relativ viele chatter im discord lasst mich mal ertäuschen wir haben relativ
viele aktive chatter sogar so viele dass wir fast theoretisch partner werden könnten
ja das stimmt das stimmt ich gucke auch viele sachen also gerade so weltall themen finde
ich echt spannend
excellent emotes ja ja ich studiere das nicht ich finde das aber halt eine spannende sache
in binary am ungerade zahlt immer eine 1 und das kannst du genau genau genau genau korrekt
stimmt so war das du schiftest ist kurz das letzte bit und dann kannst du gucken ja genau
gibt sicherlich noch 50 verschiedene varianten wie man das machen kann in line sampler kannst
du sicherlich auch machen was hältst du von zertifikaten im artiebereich ich nix manche
old school unternehmen in deutschland schon
paints jam ja ja das ist die geschichte das sind das sind so sachen die finde ich beispielsweise
echt echt interessante interessante sachen also da geht es ja darum beim großen filter
geht es ja darum um eine der gründe warum wir noch keine außerirdischen gefunden haben
und eine der gründe warum wir keine außerirdischen gefunden haben könnte sein dass eine zivilisation
die fortschrittlich genug ist sich früher oder später selbst plattmacht oder dass irgendwas
passiert was sie aussterben lässt noch bevor sie sich auf mehrere planeten ausgebreitet
haben und wisst ihr was das wisst ihr was das das das beunruhigende daran ist wir sind
kurz davor weil theoretisch sobald sich eine zivilisation auf mehrere planete oder gar
mehrere sonnensysteme ausgebreitet hat kann kann sie ja nur noch schwer aussterben und
ich mein solange wird es nicht mehr dauern bis wir eventuell mal auf einem anderen planet
sind bei uns im sonnensystem also ich denke nicht dass ich das dann auch irgendwie um
tausende jahre handelt vielleicht sterben wir demnächst aus du kannst auch bei einer
string konvertieren ob die letzte das kannst du auch machen ja das ist das jahr 3000 das
jahr 3000 problem leute abschaltungen der cobalt mainframes die letzten dinger laufen
noch irgendwo in irgendeinem bunker abgeschottet von der restlichen menschheit ist der plan
von ilon masken schon ilon maske hat viele pläne wenn der tag lang ist es ist aber schon
erstaunlich genug dass sogar ein teil davon auch wirklich klappt aber anteilmäßig von
dem was er so sagt zu dem was klappt ist es immer noch ein kleiner prozentsatz aber immerhin
exquisite
das kann sein ja ist echt so cobalt programmierer sind voll gefragt wenn denn mal einer gesucht
wird dann bezahlen sie dem viel ja also insofern gefahren wenn sie gefragt sind dann sind
sie richtig gefragt und gibt kohle ganz im ernst aber wer cobalt freiwillig machte kriegst
der anfälle ich glaube ich glaube heute lässt man cobalt lieber in indien programmieren
oder sowas bei peta von microsoft support ja da ist da ist was dran ja aber er zählt
schon viel zeug was so nicht werden wird auch diese geschichte mit diesem tunnel damit
wie heißt das mit diesem vakuum tunnel und zügen und so das mit dem leben nichts und
auch ob starlink was wird habe ich also starlink für die versorgung von äh quasi von von
privaten haushalten mit mit schnell im internet da habe ich ganz große zweifel dass das was
wird da starlink anwendungsgebiete hat das ist klar manche sagen ja zum beispiel für
hochfrequenz trading wäre starlink äußerst interessant wie das mit weltraumschrott aussieht
ich bin ja naja das skylink prinzipiell funktioniert ist ja absolut nichts neues wir übertragen
ja quasi daten von der erde zu satteliten und zurück schon lange die dinger sind jetzt
ein bisschen tiefer die frage wird eher sein funktioniert das ähm wenn du da auch mal
wirklich ein paar leute anschließt weil du musst ja dann du musst ja dann bedenken okay
ähm damit du von dort wo du wo du deinen standort hast wahrgenommen du bist in irgendeinem
dorf dass du woanders hinkommst also du musst ja quasi hoch zum sattelit und dann von einem
sattelit zum anderen zum anderen satteliten dann da wieder runter und da ist die frage
wenn es ein paar leute benutzen ob die bandbreite schlicht nur greifen ausreicht und selbst
wenn man da sehr großzügige sachen schätzt ich habe der letzte sogar mal irgendwo ein
video zugesehen selbst wenn man äußerst großzügige übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten
inzwischen satteliten schätzt ist das fragwürdig ob du da wirklich viele leute mit anbinden
kannst die clouds sind drunter wir können ja vielleicht wir können ja vielleicht auf
der venus oder so unsere server hinstellen da haben sie viele viele wolken und angeblich
sind die wolken auf der venus auch in in höhen regionen wo es angenehm ist also temperatur
technisch ja warum das wie bei google stadia negativ latency brauchst du einfach nur genug
von der habe ich auch schon ein paar sachen geguckt ja das wirklich gut
habe ich mitbekommen ist abgefackelt so leute 22 23 ich gehe jetzt pennen mir tut schon
wieder der kopf weh ein bisschen benebelt vom viel vom rechner setzen ich muss jetzt
erstmal mich ein bisschen schonen also leute wir sehen uns macht's gut bis morgen da gibt
es c++ action wenn es meinen kopf zulässt bis dann zu